Ja, meine lieben Zuschauer, herzlich willkommen zurück bei Freak Shopping 24 am Morgen. Wir sind hier wieder zusammen mit unserer bezaubernden Mindy, mit John, mit Bob und unserem immer kritischen Verbraucher Jimbo. Wir haben heute schon einige Highlights gesehen, zum Beispiel den Universal Gardena Adapter auf Nasendusche. Dieser ist leider schon ausverkauft, aber ich kann Ihnen verraten, von unserem nächsten Highlight haben wir genau 100 Stück auf Lager. Also falls Ihnen gefällt, was Sie sehen, greifen Sie zum Hörer und rufen Sie die Nummer neben Ihrer Landesflagge an. Also dann Mindy, Bob, was haben wir hier vor uns?
Immer dann, wenn man es braucht, ist es nicht da oder nicht mehr brauchbar.
Toilettenpapier.
Damit das jetzt ein Ende hat, gibt es den wasserdichten Outdoor Toilettenpapierhalter von Ortlieb. Unterwegs wird das Papier in den reißfesten Teepack transportiert. Am Ziel angelangt, hängt die Rolle auch schon in der geöffneten Tasche. Und ist vorwiegend geschützt.
Weiß nicht, finde ich besser. Weil ich will das Display nicht ungeschützt in meinen Taschen, wo Schlüssel und andere Dinge immer so rum... Also so kann ich das in jede Tasche...
Ach so, weil es sozusagen von beiden Seiten ist und so, ja okay, das verstehe ich. Aber Rausziehen ist mir irgendwie zu bekloppt.
Deswegen habe ich eine Folie vorne drauf.
Folie, Folie, da bin ich...
Ich habe halt eh die Paranoia-Folie ja drauf, was ganz Geiles in der Bahn. Kann ja niemand beim was auch immer zugucken.
Achso, das ist auch noch so ein Privacy-Future.
Aber der Winkel war jetzt gar nicht mal so gut.
Du solltest es auch anmachen, Huckel.
Ist doch.
Achso, ich sehe es nämlich gerade nicht. Ich sehe einen schwarzen Bildschirm.
Es erinnert mich sehr daran, ich habe ja Südseite Fenster und mache gerade viel Homeoffice. Wenn ich mittags bei diesem Sonnenschein immer total geblendet dachte ich mir, alles klar, ich habe ja eine tolle Segelsonnenbrille mit polarisierten Gläsern, super. Tja, leider genau die falsche Richtung. Mein Display ist dann schwarz und ich muss meinen Kopf so 90 Grad drehen, damit ich was sehe.
So, letzter Punkt vielleicht zum iPhone.
Die Kamera ist gorgeous.
Das ist aber dieselbe wie beim 8 Plus, oder?
Die ist nochmal ein bisschen besser.
Weil sie eine 1,8, oder eine 2,4er Blende hat, und die andere eine 2,8?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der einzige Unterschied ist, aber dass es einen, einen, einen... Also, es gibt einen Unterschied. Ansonsten mag das technisch auf derselben Basis sein, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau. Aber, ähm... Ich bin nur total... Ich meine, ich bin ja auch nicht so ein Fotonerd. Für mich hat das einfach immer nur ganz, ganz praktische Gründe. Und der praktische Grund in dem Fall ist halt einfach die Zahl von Fotos, die auch noch bei ziemlicher Dunkelheit sehr gut werden, ist extrem hoch.
Das ist jedes Mal...
Also das haut mich echt total vom Hocker. Also auch wenn man so in irgendeinem Dämmerlicht mal irgendwas dokumentieren will, da hast du fast kein Rauschen drauf. Und das letzte Licht, was noch irgendwo rumhängt, klar halt auch nicht dieser Porträt-Modus, aber für normale Fotos auf jeden Fall völlig ausreichend.
Das ist immer so der Moment, wo ich denke, okay, also die Kamera ist wahrscheinlich wirklich ganz gut, weil ich glaube, in 90 Prozent der Fälle, wo es genau um so was geht, so in so einem Schummerlicht was zu dokumentieren, in irgendeinem Dokument nochmal abzufotografieren etc., wo dann so die ganzen Billo-Androids alle komplett die Hände hochreißen und wahrscheinlich auch die älteren iPhones. Und dann kann man damit wirklich, wie Tim schon sagt, relativ rauscharm und definiert das Ding abbilden. Das ist wirklich ziemlich cool.
Ja, das ist auch eines der Hauptgründe für so ein Telefon mittlerweile. Also für mich jedenfalls. Die gute Kamera ist schon einfach.
Der Anlass war für mich ja tatsächlich nur größerer Bildschirm. Weil ich einfach mal mehr mit Fotos arbeiten wollte für diese ganze 360-Grad-Geschichte, über die wir ja schon gesprochen haben. Und das hat sich auch in der Hinsicht gelohnt. Kleiner Nebeneffekt noch, ich finde auch einfach mal so laute Lautsprecher dazu haben, ist auch manchmal ganz praktisch. Und zu guter Letzt, Klinkenanschluss, habe ich keinen mehr. Ich habe noch nicht mal so einen Adapter.
Wie sind das nicht?
Keiner dabei? Bei mir war keiner dabei.
Bist du sicher? Guck dir die Pappe nochmal an, ob du da wirklich jede Seite genau angeschaut hast.
Die legen einen Audioadapter dabei? Bist du sicher?
Also bei mir war einer dabei. Der klebte da in dieser weißen Pappe, neben den ganzen Adaptern, war dann irgendwo auf einer dieser Ebenen auch dieser Adapter drinne.
Ah, hier sind ja auch noch die Kopfhörer. Die hab ich auch noch nicht benutzt. Ah, stimmt. So weit bin ich noch gar nicht gekommen. Hier ist sogar noch ein Kabel. Und noch ein Ladegerät. Schau an.
Braucht man alles nicht mehr.
Musst nie wieder laden.
Alright.
Ja, ne, ich bin ja vor einiger Zeit auf die neueste Generation Bluetooth-Kopfhörer umgestiegen und muss sagen, das ist schon ein schöneres Leben. Weil mir sind einfach die Kabel dann doch echt ganz schön auf den Senkel gegangen. So generell. Und auch weil ich mal einen strategischen Fehler gemacht habe. Ich hab nämlich die Griffe meines Küchenmobiljahrs so ausgewählt, dass die links und rechts leicht überstehen, weißt du? Und T-mäßig überhaupt nicht über die Konsequenzen nachgedacht. Und wenn du dann halt mit so lang rumhängenden Kopfhörer irgendwie in der Küche hin und her marschierst, haust du dir die Dinge mal so brutal vom Helm irgendwie. Hängen bleibst, dann kratzschang! Und da muss das einfach vorbei sein. So, und dann hab ich mich dann doch mit den Beats angefreundet, nachdem ich hier die Solo 3 mal getestet habe, dann hab ich die verloren. Und hab mir jetzt die Studio-Dinger geholt, weil die ja auch Noise-Cancellation haben, wo ich jetzt wegen viel Reiserei dann auch mal der Meinung war, dass ich das vielleicht mal ausprobieren müsste. Funktioniert soweit eigentlich auch ganz gut. Ich hab immer noch nicht den direkten Vergleich mit den Bose.
Aber die erste Generation hat sich vielleicht auch wieder was getan, aber ich bin damit auch sehr glücklich.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob Apple überhaupt mithalten kann in der Qualität der Noise-Cancellation. Das ist mir nicht bekannt. Soweit hat es für mich jetzt erstmal funktioniert. Also es ist auf jeden Fall besser als ohne. Ja, so. Und das hat man einfach keine Kabel mehr. Und das macht sich irgendwie ganz gut.
Ich bin ja nach wie vor Kabel-Freund.
Ich auch, vor allem weil man dann sicher gehen kann, dass man seine Tasche mal aus dem Mantel nehmen kann, ohne dass dir das Telefon geklaut wird. Die Hand aus dem Mantel. Ich hab immer mein Telefon sonst in der Hand. Aber so würdest du es halt mitbekommen, wenn es dir geklaut wird. Ein schöner Nebeneffekt beim Kabeltimpf. Du fährst nicht so oft mit den Öffis wahrscheinlich.
Ich steck mir das Telefon halt einfach dahin, wo es nicht geklaut werden kann.
Ja, aber ich komm nicht immer an meinen Sport-BH so gut an bei den Wintertagen. Das ist ja wirklich nach wie vor meine Go-To-Tasche, wo mein Telefon reinkommt, in der Tat, wenn ich unterwegs bin. Aber bei den Tagen mit diesen fetten Mänteln und Wolljacken, ist das halt schwierig, dann ranzukommen. Ich hab immer nur Kleider an.
Das ist so ein bisschen...
Sorry, na ja, kannst du ja nicht so eine spezielle iPhone-Tasche machen? Irgendwo, die irgendwo ist. So am Umkörperbereich.
Ich muss so spontan an das denken, was meine Großeltern mir früher aus dem Urlaub mitgebracht haben, diese Geldtäschchen, die man um den Hals gehangen bekommen hat.
Ja, daran dachte ich jetzt nicht, aber keine Ahnung. Klett irgendwie.
Ja, das bleibt an der Strumpfhose wieder hängen und dann ist die Strumpfhose wieder am Arsch.
Was macht ihr denn?
Lassen wir das.
Vielleicht möchte ich doch ganz kurz wissen, was du meinst.
Nein, nein. Das ist ja eine Familiensendung hier.
Wie, hast du noch keinen Explicit-Flag?
Nein, das werde ich auch niemals setzen in meinem Leben. Aus Protest mache ich das schon nicht.
Jetzt muss ich mich ja zurückhalten.
Genau, halte ich mal ein bisschen zurück. Vielleicht können wir ja mal auf irgendeine der Themen kommen, die wir noch auf unserer Liste hatten. Moment, wollen wir denn weitermachen?
Du meinst die Sendung starten?
Genau, jetzt nach der Einleitung und dem Intro.
Ich hätte vielleicht noch so ein paar Hausmeistereien, die vielleicht auch nochmal zur Sprache kommen sollten. Also einerseits, ich mache morgen ein Hörerinnen-Treffen in Mainz. Das ist am 1. März. Das wird jetzt für die meisten Leute schon zu spät sein, wenn sie diese Sendung hören. Aber es gibt ja auch ein paar Live-Hörer, keine Ahnung. Dazu vielleicht grundsätzlich was. Ich bin jetzt mal wieder ein bisschen häufiger unterwegs, als ich das so in den letzten zwei Jahren war. Unter anderem dadurch, dass ich mir ja mal wieder eine Bahncard 100 geholt habe. So in der Hoffnung, dass sich das irgendwie rentiert. Aber es bringt einem immer dazu, sich dann doch mehr mal durch die Republik zu bewegen. Und da wollte ich dann auch mal eine gute alte Tradition aufnehmen. Und mich mal wieder ein bisschen blicken lassen, mal wieder ein paar Leute treffen, wieder treffen und überhaupt erstmal kennenlernen. Insofern, wenn das was für euch ist grundsätzlich, ich kündige das dann immer so, naja, vielleicht derzeit noch zu kurzfristig, aber vielleicht demnächst mal nicht immer ganz so kurzfristig an, über Twitter und schreib in der Regel auch immer was in meinem Blog, wo man sich dann kurz melden kann. Und dann ist es immer super, wenn sich jemand findet, der mal eben auch noch einen Raum klarmachen kann. Und dann findet das in der Regel auch ganz unkompliziert statt. Und das ist eigentlich auch sehr nett, ich hatte jetzt vor zwei Wochen, zwei, drei Wochen das in Köln gemacht. Und ja, da ist mir dann gleich wieder aufgefallen, warum ich das früher so oft und so gerne gemacht habe. Weil es einfach immer nette Leute sind, die man trifft. Dann hab ich noch so eine ganz dumme Sache. Ich hab mir die ganze Zeit, vor einem Jahr, hab ich mir mal so ein Audio Interface gekauft, mit dem hab ich nie dazu gekommen, das mal auszuprobieren. Und neulich dachte ich mir so, jetzt! Jetzt nimmst du das nochmal so richtig in die Hand und jetzt ist genau der Zeitpunkt gekommen. Da hab ich mir so, wo ist das Scheißteil? Wo ist das Scheißteil? Und dann fiel mir irgendwann ein, Mann, das hast du jemand geliehen. Aber natürlich hab ich mir nicht gemerkt, an wen. Mir fällt's nicht ein.
So was schreibt man sich doch auch.
Ja, natürlich. Ich hab auch schon überall geguckt, ob ich's mir irgendwo aufgeschrieben habe. Und es macht mich auch ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen kirre. Und es muss auch irgendwie eine Person sein, die mir irgendwie da steht. Keine Ahnung. Aber mir fällt's einfach nicht mehr ein. Also in der Hoffnung, dass du irgendwie diese Sendung auch hörst, bitte meldet es. Ich brauch mein scheiß Audio-Interface wieder zurück. Das war gar nicht so billig. Und, ja, keine Ahnung.
Ein Focus-Ride, Claret 4. Also nur, damit die Leute vielleicht jetzt so die Glückchen klingeln.
Genau, das rote Focus-Ride bitte, was da im Regal liegt, da oben rechts. Ja, genau das.
Das bitte zu mir.
Zum Thema Focus-Ride. Die haben wir jetzt ja auch bei der NAMM-Show. Ich weiß nicht, hast du die auch auf dem Radar? Diese, ist ja eher Musik.
Auf dem Radar würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Ich weiß, dass es die gibt und dass die einmal im Jahr stattfinden.
Genau, das ist ja nicht so für Recording-Equipment primär. Da gibt es ja dann die AES oder wie die heißt. Aber, nichtsdestotrotz, ich glaube, da hat Focus-Ride dann auch schon die als erster Hersteller so USB-C-Geräte quasi gelauncht. Und im Wesentlichen haben sie jetzt ihre, wenn ich mich... War es die Clarett oder die Scale 3, die sie jetzt mit USB-C gemacht haben?
Ja, bestimmt die Clarett, weil das ist ja eh schon Thunderbolt. Wird das jetzt unter USB?
Ah, da steht es schon. Klickt mal auf dieses USB, weil die haben eher auf... Genau, Clarett USB heißt die Serie. Und da gibt es halt USB-C, aber auch tatsächlich noch einen alten USB-Anschluss, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Ja, fand ich auf jeden Fall ganz cool, dass da Focusrite jetzt mittlerweile wirklich auch ziemlich vorne mit dabei ist.
Also, sie reden eigentlich von Thunderbolt.
Ja, klar.
Aber weil Leute das nicht verstehen, sagen sie jetzt USB-C...
Also sie haben halt auch den USB-C-Stecker hinten dran.
Ja gut, aber wenn du es halt an ein Gerät ohne USB-C mit Thunderbolt steckst, also an MacBook hast du immer noch keinen Thunderbolt.
Äh, was nochmal?
Ein MacBook.
Hat USB-C Ports. Macht darüber aber nur USB.
Ach, dieses MacBook mit nur einem Ports.
Genau. Das ein Port MacBook, MacBook, MacBook.
Aber dann würde das hier zu normalem USB zurückfallen?
Ja, aber ich meine, dann...
Jaja, aber gut, wer sich ein MacBook kauft, kauft sich vielleicht auch nicht so ein mehrere hundert Euro Audio Interface dazu.
Ich sag nur, ist alles nachvollziehbar irgendwie, da mussten sie jetzt hier nicht viel machen, aber das ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen die Software, die sie vorher hatten, nur mit einem anderen Stück.
Aber du kennst ja die Hersteller und wie langsam die sonst so sind. Also es gibt ja jetzt noch Hersteller, die Geräte mit Thunderbolt 1 releasen. Und da finde ich ja den Ansatz schon so ein bisschen sportlicher. Wir wissen, was da gerade passiert und wir warten nicht drei Jahre, bis wir dann mal einen neuen Stecker hinten und so weiter rausbringen, sondern gleich mit dabei. War ja auch nur eine kleine Randnotiz, ist jetzt auch keine revolutionäre Nachricht, ich fand es nur ganz schön.
Ja, genau dieses Claretta, das hätte ich jetzt ganz gerne mal wieder.
Genau, das passt jetzt auch ganz thematisch ganz gut dazu.
Genau.
Ansonsten wollte ich mich nochmal kurz bedanken für die Spender der Metaebene, die das Programm hier immer so wunderbar unterstützen. Und das gibt mir die Kraft, solche E-Mails gleich wieder zurück zu feuern, wie ich sie noch kurz vor dieser Sendung bekommen habe, wo mich wieder irgendein Webseitenhansel irgendwie dazu bringen wollte, hier meine Zielgruppe zu verschleudern und irgendwie meine Zielgruppen Daten zu nennen, meine Media-Daten zu nennen und was ich denn so für Downloads hätte und überhaupt.
Und du hast ihnen ein virtuelles Fuck you gegeben.
Ich schreibe halt zurück, wie ich es immer mache. Also wenn ich zurückschreibe, schreibe ich halt, ich mache keine Werbung.
Außer Eigenwerbung.
Bleibt mir vom Leib. Ich mache Eigenwerbung, ich halte es auch in Grenzen. Ich weiß allerdings auch oder habe zumindest eine Ahnung, was solche Werbedeals halt an Geld schon lösen können. Das würde schon das eine oder andere einfacher machen, in Anführungsstrichen. Nur dann sind halt auf einmal andere Leute meine Kunden. Und das will ich halt nicht.
Du willst ja eigentlich keine Kunden.
Nee, das Wort ist unpassend so. Aber ich meine, wenn ich darüber nachdenke, für wen ich was mach, abgesehen, dass ich viele natürlich auch für mich mach, äh, probier ich ja das zu machen, damit's gefällt. So, inhaltlich, dass das gefällt. Und nicht, dass es einen passenden Rahmen für Werbung hattet. Das ist das direkte Gegenteil von dem, was ich versuch, zieh ich halt jeden Tag hier aus dem Briefkasten raus. Kennst du das Elend hier, diese Tonnenweisen, diese dicken, fetten Zeitungen und so weiter, mit so 3, 4, 5 Mini-Artikeln, die man sich jetzt, wo man das Wissen jetzt nicht einen wirklich weiterbringt. Die aber im Prinzip nur Rahmen von so einem überbordenden Wuss von Anzeigen.
Habt ihr nicht so Aufkleber auf den Briefkasten?
Ja, hast du nicht Spam-Filter?
Man kann mit denen halt ganz gut Weitwurf in die Tonne üben. Also immerhin das.
Ich hab vor kurzem meinen Briefkasten dekoriert mit zwei so hübschen Keine-Labung-Aufklebern und dann noch mal so einen direkt neben dem Wurfschlitz. So keine Wurfsendung, etc., Also klar, irgendwie... Dollarumzugsfirma wirft immer noch ihren Zettel rein, aber zumindest diese Wurstblätter und Zeitungen bleiben jetzt fern. Also es hat das Volumen von Briefkasten zu Papierkorb, also die Bandbreite deutlich verringert, die nötig ist, aber...
So was könnte man einfach direkt vorne am Haus anbringen, weitergehen, nicht klingeln, nichts reinwerfen.
Ich frage mich, ob es irgendwelche Leute gibt, die das dann auch tatsächlich lesen.
Ja, gibt's. Ich habe früher ja so Zeitungen ausgetragen, in Anführungsstrichen, also so eine Wurstblätter da in Küpenick und so, um so erstes Taschengeld und so. Und natürlich so, wenn man so Teenager ist und das Wetter gerade nicht so geil ist, denkt man sich so, naja, ob ich heute die ganze Tour mache? Mal gucken, wie weit ich so komme. Und naja, dann fährt man die nächste Woche dann wieder die ganze Tour. Und dann steht da schon die Oma am Gartentor und hat schon den erhobenen Zeigefinger und wo denn die Ausgabe vom letzten Mal geblieben wäre. Und die beschweren sich dann auch. Und das kriegt man dann auch zu hören von seinen Vorgesetzten. Also es gibt Leute, die da drauf explizit warten.
Ich meine, dann passiert halt mal was in ihrem Leben. Na ja, trotzdem. Ich hab mir das ja so in den Kopf gesetzt, dass ich das so halten möchte. Weil ich mir halt schon immer gedacht hab, das muss auch anders gehen. Und das sind dann immer wieder so Momente, wo man auch immer wieder so versucht wird.
Ich find's auch cooler in der Tat, wenn jemand was im Podcast empfiehlt, weil er es gekauft hat, weil er davon wirklich überzeugt ist. Also das, finde ich, bringt einem halt auch mehr als die x-te Werbung für The Cash App oder was auch immer. Gibt's ja nicht in Deutschland, aber... Ich finde das ist halt wesentlich nerviger. Und so dieses, es wird gerade versucht mit dir Geld zu machen, was vielleicht bei einigen Sachen auch okay ist, aber...
Ja, manche Leute haben da ja auch eine andere Toleranz. Ich meine, es gibt so auch diese Grundhaltung mit, naja, dann ist das halt so, dann nehme ich das halt so mit, das trifft mich ja nicht etc. Das weiß ich nicht, ob sich das manche nur schönreden oder ob das wirklich so das Ding ist, aber ich habe schon immer eine extreme Werberesilienz gehabt. Und zwar nicht, indem ich sage, ich lasse mich nicht davon beeinflussen, sondern ich habe so eine totale Automatik des Ignorierens entwickelt. Also wenn Werbung, also ich schalte alles stumm, was mir irgendwo eingeblendet wird in unseren bekloppten YouTube-Videos, ich nehme es nicht wahr, ich scroll den Screen nach oben, ich will es gar nicht sehen, ich überblätter in Zeitungen, ohne auch nur meinen Blick darüber zu streifen zu lassen. Das hat auch schon so ein bisschen was verharmtes, aber es ist eine Automatik. Das habe ich einfach so drin. Was ja auch nicht heißt, dass ich nicht Werbung in einem bestimmten Kontext auch manchmal vielleicht auch sinnvoll fände. So was wie die ZT zum Beispiel. So eine Zeitschrift, die sich immer noch hält. Aber das war ja so in den 90er Jahren, als sie ihre Hochphase hat, da war das ja so ein dickes Paket. Viele Leute haben sich die ZT auch gerade wegen der Werbung gekauft. Weil das war halt quasi das ausgedruckte Internet mit den Computerteilepreisen. Das war so die Referenz. Was kostet das Mainboard, was kostet das, was kostet das, was kostet das? Weil das Internet in dem Sinne war noch nicht so da. Es war nicht so diese Preisvergleich hier als da. Die Rolle hat es natürlich jetzt verloren. Jetzt weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, was da überhaupt noch funktioniert etc. Irgendwas wird sicherlich noch so ein bisschen funktionieren. Vielleicht kommt da auch noch irgendwas wieder zurück, was aus irgendwelchen Gründen online nicht so klappt, wegen Werbeblockern oder weil die Leute online noch sehr viel mehr dran vorbeischauen. Aber es ist natürlich, was ich sagen will, es ist auch in Werbung natürlich immer auch ein Informationsaspekt mit drin. Und den könnte man ja auch so argumentieren. Man sagt, naja, Unternehmen, die was zu bieten haben, müssen ja auch Sichtbarkeit bekommen. Ist ja auch klar. Ich meine, stell dir mal vor, wir hätten jetzt sowieso ein Produkt, für das wir so noch keine Öffentlichkeit haben und was aus irgendwelchen Gründen sich nicht so ohne Weiteres über Mundpropaganda verbreitet oder wenn, dann halt nicht so schnell. Du musst da sowieso viel Geld in die Hand nehmen, weil sich das sonst nicht lohnt. Pipapo, Massenmarkt und dann, naja, was macht man dann? Wie machst du dann dein Marketing? Worauf legst du dann Wert? Würde ich zu Podcasts gehen, um mein Produkt zu verbreiten?
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht würde ich das tun. Podcasts sind eigentlich eine geile Audience. So ist es ja auch nicht. Also es ist schon verlockend. Ich kann das verstehen. Ich verstehe vollkommen, warum das so erfolgreich ist in den USA und warum es vielleicht auch teilweise hier funktioniert. Ich hab bloß nur keine Lust da mitzuspielen. Ich will überhaupt nicht über Preislisten nachdenken und dieses ganze Gefeilsche, was damit zu tun ist. Und wie gesagt, ich will halt auch andere Kunden haben. Ich will nicht mit Marketingabteilungen reden, sondern ich will lieber Hörerkommentare lesen und irgendwie auf Twitter mich mit allen über das Programm unterhalten. Das ist für mich viel, viel, viel interessanter. Muss aber dann eben auch funktionieren. Insofern nochmal Danke für die Unterstützung. Alles, was ihr übrig habt, ist hier wohl angelegt.
Danke auch wieder mal an Spender oder Hörer, die von der Amazon-Wunschliste Dinge schicken.
Hast du da immer so viele Sachen drauf?
Was willst du denn noch zu haben?
Ich nutze die halt so, auch um die an meinen Eltern zu schicken. Du hast gesagt, man braucht sowas, wenn man podcastet. Ich habe mich nur dem gefügt. Deswegen danke an alle.
Solange du dich immer an meinen Rat hältst, Letty, dann kann dir eh nichts passieren.
Ja, ich fange jetzt an mit Lua zu arbeiten. Und Buchhaltung. Nein!
Das war jetzt ein bisschen gemein.
Ich hab mir zwar wirklich als Ziel gesetzt, mir das jetzt noch mit der ganzen Steuergeschichte und selbstständig und so weiter wirklich auch nochmal genauer anzugucken.
Aber so weit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen.
Am Ende haben wir dann hier eine komplette Freak Show nur über Buchhaltung. Wo ist denn der Herr Urbach, wenn man von ihm spricht?
Der reagiert bestimmt schon auf Twitter. Oder überreagiert. Ja, du, also, wir können uns ja gerne nochmal in dem Bein unterhalten. Aber ich sag dir ja irgendwie, die volle Automatisierung heißt auch die volle Ruhe.
Das Schlimme ist, ich mag ja, das kann man gar nicht so laut sagen, so repetitive, langweilige Aufgaben von Zeit zu Zeit. Und ich meine, die Art und Weise, wie du in, also kann ja jetzt nur von dem kleinen Einblick in Buchhaltung, was ich in diesem Autohaus mal hatte, berichten. Es war aber schon so, dass du immer wieder schon das Gleiche machst. Ja, hier und da, wo sind die Konten, da buchst du das hin, soll da haben, fein, passt, nächster Zettel und das ist schon so ein bisschen geil. Ich glaube, ich hätte auch bei anderen, für andere Leute langweilige Aufgaben wahrscheinlich meinen Spaß.
Man braucht natürlich immer neue Herausforderungen.
Schon vor der GmbH-Gründung?
Nein, ich schalte jetzt in die nächste.
Aktiengesellschaft?
Nein, also jetzt haben wir erst mal Refinement irgendwie. Man muss wirklich so selbstständigen To-Go-mäßig unterwegs sein. Man muss das einfach so optimieren. Und dann kann man sich irgendwie auch mal wieder um neue Herausforderungen kümmern. Vor allem möchte ich ja gerne, dass diese ganzen Bezahldinger da draußen auch irgendwie, dass alles eigentlich, was du im Netz machst mit Geld, irgendwie sichtbar wird. Also zum Beispiel, haben wir das schon über gesprochen? Weiß ich mal nicht so genau. Du hast ja diese ganzen Portale, was weiß ich hier so? Patreon, diese Spenden-Dinger oder jetzt Liberapay, was ich ja immer noch sehr, sehr cool finde. Da hoffe ich auch, dass da bald mal was so in diese Richtung passiert. Also nehmen wir das als Beispiel, weil das ist eigentlich sehr konkret. Hat ich glaube ich schon mal erwähnt, Liberapay ist so ein neuer Spenden-Rotier-Dienst, der den großen Vorteil hat, dass er komplett auf einer Non-Profit-Organisation basiert und komplett Open Source ist. Dementsprechend natürlich auch in der freien Software-Szene jetzt erstmal so seine Liebhaber findet, aber sich schon so ein bisschen rumspricht. Da habe ich irgendwie auch mal so einen Topf aufgestellt, weil das sind so die Dienste, die ich irgendwie gut leiden kann. Und beobachte das derzeit erstmal so ein bisschen. Gucke mal, was da so geht. Und natürlich machst du da quasi ein Konto auf. Das ist zwar keine Bank, aber es ist so eine Geldschnittstelle. Und wenn du deine Kosten und überhaupt dein Hin und Her, also egal, ob du wirklich jetzt Buchhaltung machen musst oder ob du nur privat irgendwie was haben willst, dann wäre es ja sinnvoll, dass du quasi, so wie du deinen ganzen Bankkonten verwaltest, im Idealfall mit irgendeinem Tool, auch solche Geldschnittstellen auch auf dieselbe Art und Weise siehst. In meinem konkreten Beispiel wäre das Money Money, weil ich das halt benutze und weil das eben auch programmierbar ist und gegen Apis programmiert werden kann. Es gibt ja jetzt für Money Money mittlerweile eine riesige Liste von Extensions, vor allem auch für diese ganzen Bitcoin-Plattformen. Ja, ich geb das mal hier kurz noch in den Chat mit rein. Hier Bestandsabfrage für Bitcoin, Bitcoin Cash, Bitstamp, Coinbase, Balala. Bitcoin holt er sich dann halt direkt quasi von der Chain und ist dann halt pro Adresse. Weil deine Wallet ist ja in dem Sinne nicht im Netz, sondern du musst sozusagen auch alles irgendwie in einem Ding...
Ja, bei mir reicht Coinbase.
Genau, oder Coinbase eben. Also all diese ganzen Sachen und auch so Banken, die jetzt nicht HBCI unterstützen, werden da halt drin gemacht. Und leider hat Liberapay zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt noch nicht eine API dafür, aber das ist so da in der Diskussion. Hängt da so ein bisschen im Chat ab und guckt mal so worauf reagiert wird. Und das könnte also durchaus passieren, dass es da so im Laufe des Jahres irgendwann mal so eine API gibt, womit man dann eben sich authentifiziert, sagt hier mein Account und dann kriegst du quasi auch deine ganzen Einnahmen und Ausgaben über dieses API so abgebildet und hättest sie dann eben auch so in Money Money. Das finde ich irgendwie, das muss so ein bisschen die nächste Realität sein. Dass man dieses ganze Hin und Her von Geldscheinchen, dass es einfach Transparenz hat für einen selbst, im Zweifelsfall eben auch fürs Finanzamt, dass man die ganzen Dinge auch einfach belegen kann. Was das jetzt für ein Stress war, irgendwie da mal sowas wie Flatter mal wirklich auch nachzuweisen. Haben sie auch Kontoauszüge und so? Schwierig und so. Dann gab es dann endlich mal irgendwelche merkwürdigen PDFs, die irgendwie auch so nicht ganz echt aussahen, aber das Einzige waren, was da ist. Man kennt das ja. Da schalten jetzt auch alle so zunehmend zu hin. Bei PayPal gibt es jetzt die Möglichkeit, sich Geschäftskonto zu machen. Da kriegst du dann auch mal ordentliche Kontoauszüge, PDFs, wo was drinsteht. Man mag sich selber nicht so viel aus diesen PDFs machen, aber Finanzämter stehen da drauf. Ganz tolle Sache. Naja, uns am Ende auch alles ganz hilfreich.
Naja, Geld regiert die Welt.
Und im Internet muss das alles transparent werden.
Ich hätte ja mal noch ein ganz anderes Thema im Angebot, was mich die letzten Wochen in meiner Abwesenheit sehr fasziniert hat. Und da ja unter den Podcast-Hörern sicherlich auch die eine oder anderen Eltern und werdenden Eltern sind, habe ich für euch im Speziellen jetzt eine Anregung, wie ihr eurem Kind, eurem zukünftigen Kind vielleicht irgendwie nochmal einen ganz besonderen, ja, weiß nicht, auch nicht Input geben könnt. Und zwar... Und zwar, ich pack mal hier ein Video in den Chat. Das kannst du ja abspielen. Ich kann auch kurz beschreiben, worum es da geht. Und zwar ist das Thema Perfect Pitch, also die Fähigkeit absolutes Gehör zu haben, also Noten und Töne zu hören und zu wissen, was jetzt ein B ist und wie das klingt oder Akkorde. Und da gibt es hier so ein Video.
Soll ich das mal anspielen?
Weil das ist, bevor du das jetzt... Mach noch mal kurz Pause vielleicht. Ich erklär noch kurz, also der Vater hier, Rick Beato, so ein Jazz-Musiker, hat jetzt also seinen Sohn dahin mal trainiert. Und der ist jetzt, glaube ich, in dem Video sechs. Und er spielt am Piano Akkorde oder Noten. Und er guckt in die andere Richtung und muss halt sagen, was das für Akkorde sind oder Töne oder die singen.
Und jetzt soll ich das abspielen. Wir machen dann ein paar Intervallen und dann Körner.
Ach, das war's schon. Da gibt's noch, glaub ich, fünf weitere Parts und die werden immer krasser. Das war jetzt noch nicht das Krasse, ne? Nee, nee, nee, also Part 2 fand ich sogar mit am krassesten. Das Beeindruckende bei dem ist nicht nur, dass er absolutes Gehör hat, sondern dass er auch die Noten identifiziert, die Intervalle kennt und wenn er Akkorde spielt und auch diese komplexen Akkorde, die einfach strukturiert, korrekt aufsagt und nicht nur einfach random die Noten in den Akkorden sagt, sondern in der richtigen Reihenfolge und irgendwie auch die Akkorde richtig benennt. Und das ist einfach ultra krass. Na ja, und davon hat er dann ein paar Videos gemacht und hat dann auch irgendwann angefangen zu erklären, wer kann überhaupt Perfect Pitch haben, woher kommt das, was ist das? Und es gibt halt ein Gen, was damit in Verbindungen gebracht wird, was angeblich, glaube ich, 10% der Menschen haben. Er hat dann gleich mal sich und seine Familie so testen lassen, ob sie das dann so haben. Und tatsächlich, er und alle seine Kinder haben das, aber er selber hat keinen Perfect Pitch zum Beispiel. Also das Gen alleine reicht auch nicht. Und es gibt auch Leute, die auch ohne das Gen Perfect Pitch haben. Und dann gibt es halt so ein paar Videos, die kann ich euch auch empfehlen. Ich pack noch ein paar Links in die Show Notes dann, die entsprechenden Videos, weil er erklärt, wie er das seinen Kindern sozusagen beigebracht hat. Und im Wesentlichen basiert das halt so darauf, dass in den ersten tausend Tagen oder so in dem Dreh von Kindern, das fängt auch potenziell schon im Mutterleib an, das Hirn sozusagen am aufnahmefähigsten ist und sozusagen die ganze Zeit so Input, Input, Input und sich wiederholende Patterns, die werden dann halt irgendwie statistisch gehäuft und verfestigt. Und zum Beispiel, wenn ein Kind mehrsprachig aufwächst, ist das halt auch schon sozusagen geht in die gleiche Richtung, weil es dann eben nicht nur eine Muttersprache schon von vornherein immer die ganze Zeit hört und da drauf irgendwie Pattern matcht, sondern irgendwie schon das Spektrum ein bisschen weiter aufzieht. Und da gibt es auch so ein paar Interviews mit so Leuten, die auch sich mit dieser Ausbildung von dem Perfect Pitch beschäftigt haben, die dann halt so meinen, naja, zum Beispiel bei Farben gibt es halt auch das ganze Spektrum und alle möglichen Abstufungen, aber wir sagen halt von vornherein so Himmel ist blau und das ist rot und so weiter und dann benennt einfach auch so bestimmte Dinge die ganze Zeit, zum Beispiel für Kids und Kinder. Und bei Tönen macht man das aber nicht, ja? Man sagt jetzt nicht so, ja, ach das ist ein C und so weiter. Und was er gemacht hat, er hat nicht nur sozusagen so Jazz und klassische Musik den Kids schon vorgespielt, auch so mit Kopfhörern am Bauch, jeden Tag eine Stunde und so. Und dann später auch abends zum Einschalten. Er hat dann auch noch so eine Kompilation gemacht, wo er dann irgendwie so einen sehr atmosphärischen, schwebenden Klang, so hier ist ein C-Sharp, die einzelnen Töne angespielt und benannt. Dann nochmal C-Sharp, nochmal die Töne. Und dann noch so eine kleine Melodie nur mit diesen Tönen aus dem Akkord gespielt. Und das dann halt so auch jeden Tag, so eine halbe Stunde abends zum Einschlafen und so. Nur um die Affizitionsketten davor zu füllen. Genau, dieses Pattern-Matching und Verknüpfung und so weiter zu machen. Und er hat dann noch so ein paar interessante Aspekte vorgebracht, also sowieso Leute, die Perfect Pitch haben, die sprechen in der Regel bis zu sechs Sprachen dann auch fließend und so und sind sowieso ziemlich fit in Sachen Kommunikation und Gedächtnis auch. Also der kann irgendwie auch der Sohn von dem Pi auf 500 Stellen nach dem Komma sich merken oder so. Also wirklich, also dieses Kind ist ultra krass. Und wenn ihr da auf dem Kanal von dem noch ein bisschen guckt, ist wirklich Superhero. Seine Töchter sind nicht so krass, aber sie sind auch krass genug, dass er dann irgendwie solche Akkorde spielen kann und die sagen dann, ja das ist doch so und so. Also, ich meine, probieren kann man das so oder so mal, einfach so den Kindern so ein bisschen mehr musikalischen Input mitgeben und so weiter. Guckt euch mal die Videos an. Am Ende des Tages, wenn jetzt kein Perfect Pitch dabei rauskommt, also geschadet hat es höchstwahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall sehr faszinierend. Und auch diese Ausführungen eben, wie das Ganze funktioniert und ob Erwachsene auch nochmal Perfect Pitch entwickeln können oder nicht und warum nicht. Und er hat auch für Erwachsene so ein paar Videos, weil wir haben natürlich jetzt unser 1000 Tage Geburtsfenster und so weiter schon längst verpasst, aber man kann halt immer noch Pitch Memory und Relative Pitch entwickeln. Und Relative Pitch wäre sozusagen, dass man Intervalle erkennen kann und Pitch Memory ist, dass man einfach durch Übung und Wiederholung auch sich merken kann, wie ein G oder F-Sharp oder was auch immer klingt. Und dafür hat er auch ganz coole Erklärvideos. Und es gibt eine App, die hatte ich hier glaube ich auch schon vor langer Zeit mal erwähnt, nämlich heißt die Better Ears, also für die musikalischen Leute unter euch. Ich packe mal noch einen Link dazu, betterears.com heißt die URL. Und was man damit tun kann, ist halt eben genau das so Skalen und Intervalle und so trainieren und ja, genau das. Also wenn man so eine kleine musikalische Ader hat und quasi das auch können möchte oder besser können möchte und besseres Gehör haben will, dann ist die App eigentlich ganz cool. Da habe ich schon einige Stunden jetzt mit vor verbracht. Abends, wenn man sonst nichts mehr auf die Reihe kriegt, ein paar Töne hören und Intervalle identifizieren. Super. Wird auch tatsächlich immer besser. Genau, aber ich suche euch mal trotzdem noch ein paar Videos von dem raus, die, genau, How To Develop Perfect Pitch ist noch eins. Packst du die aus dem Chat rein oder soll ich die ins Workflow auch packen?
Was jetzt? Ich werfe das am besten einfach alles ins Slack rein. Du musst hier nochmal den Widerspruch deiner Aussage nochmal nacharbeiten. Mit dem Gen und so, weil das macht irgendwie alles keinen Sinn.
Ja, also das hat halt...
Also es gibt das Gen und die können das, aber auch nicht alle.
Also sagen wir mal so, was ich glaube ich noch relativ sicher sagen kann, ist, dass Leute, die das Gen haben, nicht ohne zusätzliche Stimulierung... Also das...
Die das Gen haben, brauchen keine zusätzliche Stimulierung.
Doch, brauchen sie. Also ohne dieses Training oder dieses Benennen von Tönen und Klängen und so weiter, wenn das einfach nicht trainiert wird, schon von Anfang an, dann wird das auch später nichts mehr. Also auch dann kannst du als Erwachsener da nichts mehr machen und... Also das musst du trotzdem von Anfang an quasi schon oder so früh wie möglich eigentlich simulieren.
Was hilft denn dann das Gen überhaupt?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Aber...
Irgendwas mit Genetik.
Irgendwas mit Genetik. Auf jeden Fall ist es so, dass viel mehr Leute Perfect Pitch haben als man allgemein annimmt. Also ich glaube in der Wikipedia, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo... Also eigentlich ist es so, dass die allgemeine Zahl, so einer in 10.000 hat Perfect Pitch, glaube ich. Und es stellte sich jetzt aber so in den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten raus, dass es eigentlich viel mehr Prozent ist. Und gerade zum Beispiel aus asiatischen Ländern, wo die Sprache sehr viel mehr mit Tonhöhe auch moduliert wird oder so...
China.
Ja, so Ma oder Ma, wenn es dann nach hinten noch so hoch geht, oder keine Ahnung, dass in solchen Ländern mit solchen Sprachen viel mehr Leute Perfect Pitch haben zum Beispiel. Weil das eben direkt von Anfang an die ganze Zeit, mit diesem Pattern Matching...
Ja, weil die Höhe sozusagen viel relevanter ist für die Sprache, während das ja gerade ein Problem ist in Deutschland. Wir können ja komplett ohne Tonvariante reden. Deswegen empfinden ja andere auch Deutsch, glaube ich, so als so monoton. Weil man es ja auch extrem monoton aussprechen kann.
Ich dachte, sagen wir mal, das wäre aggressiv.
Naja, das ist glaube ich das, was sie dieser Monotonie entnehmen, weil sie einfach nicht diesen Sing-Sang so mit drin haben. Also, was ich, so ein Londoner, Poscha Londoner Akzent, ich meine, das ist ja schon auch Singen. Da ist ja das Englisch, wird es ja nicht nur als Sprache geführt, sondern es ist einfach so, oh really? Ja, das gehört einfach dazu, um auch auszudrücken, was du eigentlich sagst.
Is it?
Vielleicht ist ja dein Sächsisch eigentlich total süß.
Aber so oder so ist es halt schon in anderen Sprachregionen noch ein bisschen mehr Singen, Sangen und, ne?
Na klar, noch mehr, aber in Deutschland, also nirgendswo so wenig, glaube ich, wie in Deutschland. Du kannst ja, ohne deine Tonhöhe komplett zu verändern, Deutsch sprechen, ohne irgendeine Information fallen zu lassen. Also wir sind ja mega robotisch.
Dann bringe ich noch mal das Umfahren und Umfahren aus dem Chat wieder hervor.
Die Betonung ist doch mal eine andere Sache, ne? Achso, kurzer Nachtrag dazu, das kam dann noch in den, nee, über Twitter kam es irgendwie. Man nennt, also die Diskussion, die wir letztes Mal hatten mit diesen Worten, die irgendwie gleichzeitig ihr Gegenteil bedeuten, wenn man sich nur etwas anders betont oder vielleicht auch noch nicht mal das, da gibt es ein Wort für, und zwar sind das Januswörter.
Schon mal gehört? Oh, nee.
Ja, wusste ich nämlich auch nicht.
Das ist nicht das Januswörter.
Genau. Januswörter. Ein Januswort.
Da gibt es nicht.
Nein, das weiß ich.
Ich bin in der Zeit schon Wikipedia gerade gelandet.
So, nach dem Gott Janus, auch Autoantonym, ist ein Wort mit mindestens zwei Bedeutungen, wobei eine Bedeutung das Gegenteil einer anderen ist. Auto.
Antonymie.
Januswörter verhalten sich zueinander gleich antonym, eine entgegengesetzte Bedeutung, Bedeutung habend und homonym, gleich klingend. Und dann gibt's hier verschiedene Beispiele, im Deutschen abdecken. Abdecken heißt ja, du machst irgendwas drauf, aber Dach abdecken machst weg. Allerdings... Ausbauen finde ich sehr schön. Sowohl eine Einschränkung als auch eine Bejahung und so weiter. Was noch? Ausbauen.
Werden noch etwas entfernen oder erweitern, das ist einem so nicht klar.
Das sind alles so Sachen.
Ich finde einstellen in der Tat viel interessanter, weil einstellen ist auch so ein Wort, was häufig in Gesetzestexten und so weiter vorkommt. Und du dann wirklich beim Lesen noch mal lesen solltest, was du gerade gelesen hast.
Ja, weil einstellen heißt sowohl aufkommen, also Lärm stellt sich ein, so ist es dann da. Und wenn du es einstellst, dann kannst du den Lärm auch wieder einstellen und dann ist es wieder weg. Unglaublich. Und auch sehr schön hier Quantensprung, was ja sozusagen sowohl den kleinsten als auch den größtmöglichen Schritt oder sanktionieren, sowohl bestrafen als auch billigen und gut heißen. Also muss sagen, nach Konsum dieser Wikipedia-Seite verstehe ich langsam, warum manche Leute mit Deutschland doch so ihre Schwierigkeiten haben.
Ja, aber ich meine, das kriegst du auch in anderen Sprachen hin.
Genau, wollen wir mal kurz gucken im Englischen. Auto, Antonym, da haben wir das in Englisch, oha, auch nicht gerade kurz. Gucken, ob das genauso toll ist wie im Deutschen. Ja, sowas wie Clip, kannst du was ranklippen, aber auch abklippen.
Impregnable.
Inflammable heißt gleichzeitig capable of burning und unburnable. Ja, ja, also da ist irgendwie, das ist echt interessant, wie solche Übersprünge dann so manchmal stattfinden. Wie sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen?
Sing-Sang-Sprachen.
Bei dem Video musste ich kurz so dran denken an mein Haus, mein Auto, mein übertalentiertes Kind, was ich mir rangezüchtet habe, als wäre es so ein neues Kuppen, das ich habe.
Der ist halt eh so ein Jazz-Musiker, der schon ziemlich so advanced ist und wenn du die Videos da guckst, die sind alle auch total entspannt, dass jetzt nicht so ein Drill Sergeant-mäßiges vorgeht und alles, was er gemacht hat, er hat auch so ein paar alte VHS-Videos irgendwo ausgekramt, wo er so aufgenommen hat, wie sie dann so abends statt vor dem Fernseher halt irgendwie mit dem Kind so auf dem Sofa sitzen, dann einfach so eine halbe Stunde irgendwie Klassik hören und dass das, also er hat das ja dann auch erst später rausgefunden, dass er Perfect Pitch hat, also...
Er hat das quasi unbewusst mit den Kindern?
Nö, also die Motivation weiß ich jetzt gerade genau nicht, warum er damit angefangen hat oder ob er das explizit so versucht hat, aber er meinte in einem Video dann, dass er dann irgendwie plötzlich irgendwann mal feststellte, dass er Perfect Pitch hat, weil er sich irgendwie darüber beschwert hätte, dass in einer Live-Aufnahme von seinem Lieblingssong ja die Background-Sänger total out of tune singen würden und dann... Also Moment mal, okay, lass uns mal kurz etwas testen.
Ich hab gerade auch mal überprüft hier mit Lingui, dein toller Übersetzer übersetzt tatsächlich Inflammable mit brennbar und entzündlich. Aber auch... Ah ne, aber nicht das Gegenteil, oder? Doch, ne, eigentlich nicht.
Schwer, doch, naja, die zeigen schon mal unter den Examples, mit leicht entzündlich und schwer entflammbar.
Ein paar Klammern auch.
So, To Do?
To Do oder Server?
Wir sind so grad so Meter.
Dann bleiben wir bei den To Do's, würde ich sagen. Das andere ist viel zu konkret. Ich glaube, du musst anfangen, weil du hast den Punkt gebracht, dass du auf Things...
Ich hatte das ja neulich schon mal erzählt. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich mir das eigentlich noch mal aufgeschrieben hatte, aber irgendwie...
Das war ein wiederkehrendes Thema. Das hatten wir doch vor einem halben Jahr auch schon mal.
Ja, das sind so wiederkehrende Themen.
Das sind Dinge, die die Menschheit beschäftigt.
Also wirklich, es gibt kein Problem, was in der Software-Lektüre so oft behandelt wird wie To-Do-Listen.
Und warum?
Weil es ein ungelöstes Problem ist.
Es scheint wirklich im Kern der Menschen inne zu wohnen.
Es ist wahrscheinlich deshalb so interessant, weil die Reihenfolge und die Art und Weise, wie du deine Dinge erledigst in deinem Leben, welchen Stellenwert das für dich hat und welche Motivation du brauchst, um sie zu tun, ob du sie überhaupt brauchst, ob du Erinnerungen brauchst, ob du vergesslich bist oder ob du motiviert werden musst. Das scheint so eine extrem menschliche und auch extrem persönliche Geschichte zu sein. Und jeder hat das Problem irgendwie, aber es gibt da keine einfache Lösung, weil es gibt zumindest keine universelle Lösung. Das heißt, wenn du das Problem mit Software unterstützen möchtest, dann ist das schwierig. Und es ist, glaube ich, auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise schwierig, wie auch Notizen. Und ich hab gerade vor ein paar Tagen, weiß ich gar nicht mehr wo. Aber das fand ich auch in dieser To Do Diskussion, die bei ATP war. Da meinte nämlich der Marco Amendt so, also Papier, also man meint zwar immer so Notizen und Nachschlagen und so Informationen und so weiter, da ist Software, dann meint man, dass Software sich irgendwie anbieten würde. Aber tatsächlich ist es auch so, in dem Moment, wo du etwas codest, legst du dich natürlich auch extrem fest, weil die Art und Weise, wie du Informationen ablegen kannst, wann du Informationen ablegen kannst, welche Informationen du ablegen kannst, wie du dir aufrufen kannst, etc. ist immer sehr stark festgelegt dadurch, wie du codest. Während wenn du das mit einem Blatt Papier vergleist, so Clean Slate, und du nimmst einen Stift, da kannst du deine Bullet Points machen, aber du kannst irgendwie Kreise malen, Linien malen, irgendwas schraffieren, Pipapo, die Rückseite nochmal nehmen, etc. Man wird irgendwie kreativ. Und tatsächlich ist das ja auch eine interessante Erkenntnis. Man merkt das ja auch beim Podcast hören, wenn man durch die Gegend läuft und visuelle Wahrnehmungen gleichzeitig mit der Information wahrnimmt, dann funktioniert das ja auch schon mal ganz gut. Und natürlich hast du dann auch die Möglichkeit, deine Notiz auch mehr zu visualisieren. Und wenn es nur unterstreichen, einkreisen, umkringeln.
Mit einem Textmarker nochmal ganz dinge hervorheben.
All diese ganzen Dinge sind unter Umständen auch nur Visual Entertainment, um dir aus dieser Notiz auch wirklich eine wird.
Ich hab dazu nochmal, weil du den ATP-Podcast erwähnt hast, die Folge dazu reingeschmissen. Weil die wirklich super interessant ist. Weil nämlich, ich glaube, Cassie war das ja, die dann, Cassie, die dann sagte, oder hatte den ganz interessanten Ansatz, dass eigentlich ist eine fertige Software zu haben okay, aber sie erreicht immer nur die Gruppe, für die es funktioniert. Und ob es nicht eigentlich der sinnvollere Ansatz wäre, ein, wie ein Toolkit zu haben, womit man sich seine eigene To Do App baut. Weil jeder andere Ansprüche hat, wie seine To Do List aussehen muss. Und das fand ich war auch mal ein ganz interessanter Ansatz. Es kann halt gar nicht die eine generische One-fits-all-Solution sein, sondern dass man vielleicht eher in so einem Baukasten denken müsste, um überhaupt mit einer Software wirklich allen gerecht zu werden. Und ich weiß ja nicht, wie nutzt du denn deine Things App?
Also vielleicht für die Leute, die den Prolog gar nicht mitbekommen haben. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das ist, und das ist noch gar nicht so lange her, dass wir uns darüber unterhalten haben.
Ich glaube, wir haben uns das letzte Mal zur Vorsendung unterhalten über Notiz-Apps und haben dann aber nicht darüber gesprochen, weil die Zeit weg war.
Ich hatte aber Things schon mal erwähnt. Krieg das aber jetzt nicht mehr so ganz hin. Die eigentliche Nachricht, also ich glaube, ich habe es mir deshalb notiert, weil ich wollte mir mal die ganzen Apps aufschreiben. Genau, das war nämlich mein Ansatz. Ich bin nicht sehr weit gekommen. Ich wollte mal all diese Apps aufschreiben, wo ich immer wieder feststelle, dass ich die benutze, die für mich einen echten Wert haben auf dem Mac, die aber meistens nicht so bekannt sind oder die nur so eine mega kleine Dienstleistung für einen übernehmen, dass man sie manchmal gar nicht so wahrnimmt oder als nicht so wichtig empfindet. In dem Moment, wo sie aber fehlen, lädt man sie sich sofort wieder runter, weil es geht ja gar nicht ohne. Da gibt es dann immer wieder so kleine Dinge. Alles, was bei mir eine Weile hält und mich nicht frustriert, finde ich allein aus diesem Grund schon mal ganz interessant. Das ist tatsächlich eine ganze Menge an Software. Und deswegen bin ich, glaube ich, auf Things gekommen. Und dann gab es komischerweise auf einmal um mich herum überall Leute, die dann wieder darüber sprachen. Aber vielleicht mal kurz noch mal zu Things. Also Things ist ja auch nicht ganz billig, was ich nicht unbedingt als Nachteil empfinde, weil ich mag das immer, wenn Software auch irgendwie sustainable entwickelt wird. Und ich bin auch ganz andere Softwarepreise von früher gewohnt. Da habe ich mir zwar noch nicht so viel Software gekauft wie heute, aber es hat ja auch mal ein bisschen was mit dem eigenen Einkommen und dem Verhältnis zu Geld zu tun. Ich finde das okay. Immerhin gibt es diese Software auf dem Mac und es gibt sie auf dem iPhone, weil das ist so mittlerweile meine Anforderung eigentlich an Produktivitätssoftware. Die muss eigentlich auf all meinen Plattformen verfügbar sein. Mindestens auf dem Telefon und auf meinem Laptop. Sonst ist das irgendwie nix. Und im Zweifelsfall ziehe ich auch den Mac vor. Es gibt einfach Sachen, die mache ich einfach lieber auf dem Mac und da sehe ich auch irgendwie nicht, dass das Telefon irgendwie noch mal nennenswert einen Fuß in die Tür bekommt. Einfach weil für mich die Eingabe über die Tastatur einfach immer noch die performanteste Eingabe ist, die es gibt. So, Things ist ja yet another To Do Programm, was aber bei mir einfach den Test of Time überlebt hat. Das ist eigentlich das Interessante. Ich hatte so viele To Do Apps in meinem Leben schon irgendwie und alle waren irgendwie nach zwei Monaten Vergangenheit. Damit will ich gar nicht behaupten, dass jetzt Things irgendwie der Megawurf ist, der für jeden funktioniert. Es ist nur für mich funktioniert. Das heißt, ihr könnt euch das angucken und feststellen. Aber irgendwie so diese Gruppierung von Dingen, die Kontextwechsel, den ich so ausgesetzt bin, mein Um- und Hin- und Her-Schalten zwischen, ich denke privat, ich denke mehr im Sinne von Podcastproduktion. Ich trenne die Dinge auch. Da finde ich Things, das auf eine sehr interessante Art und Weise zusammenbekommen. So Sachen wie Siri-Eingabe und so was, das ist für mich alles überhaupt nicht wichtig. Ich tippe das lieber ein. Im Kern ist es so, man wirft halt alles erstmal in so einen Eingangskorb rein. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so diese To Do-Lehre. Und dann kannst du aber jedem Dingen irgendwie ein Projekt zuordnen oder auch nicht. Und du kannst Projekte auch noch in so, wie heißt das hier eigentlich? Areas oder was? Bereiche, genau. Also Projekte und Bereiche. Und da hatte ich schon verschiedene To Do Programme, die das irgendwie mit anderen Konzepten probiert haben, mit anderen Klammern, was in was enthalten sein kann. Aber das funktioniert für mich ziemlich gut. Manchmal gibt es so Tasks, da gibt es nur so eine Sache. Das ist für mich kein Projekt irgendwie. Das gehört jetzt auch nicht in irgendeinen besonderen Bereich. Das muss ich mir einfach nur merken. Und wenn das irgendwie wichtig ist und sofort passieren muss, dann kommt das irgendwie in Today rein und fertig. Also es gibt sozusagen die Zeitachse, es gibt die Wo gehört es dazu-Achse und Wo gehört es noch konkreter dazu-Achse. Und sind das aber so Sachen wie, müsste mal ein neues Sofa für die Wohnung irgendwann mal, wenn man mal dazukommt und so, dann habe ich dann auch schon so ein Projektwohnung, der so in den Privatbereich gehört, wo ich alles reinschmeiße, mit was man mal recherchieren müsste, was man mal kaufen oder bauen oder neu machen müsste. Und so sammeln sich die Sachen da so an. Und wenn man dann ab und zu mal nachschaut, dann so, ah, okay, alles klar. Aber es drängt sich dann auch nicht auf. Es ist da irgendwie ganz gut erstmal weggespeichert. Und man kann halt jederzeit sagen, okay, ich möchte mich jetzt um diesen Bereich kümmern, dann sehe ich alle Projekte, oder ich möchte mich nur um dieses eine Projekt kümmern, dann sehe ich halt nur die Tasks, die da drin sind. Und jedes Projekt füllt sich automatisch mit jedem Task, den du da weggehakt hast. Also das geht irgendwie alles wunderbar. Dazu kommt, dass einfach das Syncing hervorragend funktioniert, also so richtig hervorragend, hervorragend. Du machst irgendwie die App auf und egal, auf wie viele anderen rechnern das gleichzeitig läuft oder nicht läuft, blums sofort ist irgendwie immer alles konsistent, kein Datenverlust, nichts. Also ich finde es super und es schickt sich gerade so an, eines dieser unverzichtbaren Dinge zu sein, die ich immer wieder gerne starte.
Ja ich nutze, also ich habe früher mal das, weiß ich auch, dass wir damals schon mal darüber gesprochen haben, den Org-Mode ein bisschen benutzt, was eine Erweiterung für das Emacs war. Was aber auf dem Mac, wie ich finde, mit Emacs zu arbeiten, ein bisschen so pain in the ass ist. Warum ich dann irgendwann aufgehört habe, mich überhaupt mit diesem Org-Mode weiter zu beschäftigen, aber das fand ich irgendwie ganz interessant, weil es dann doch eher so den Charme von der Konsole hat, irgendwie ganz nett. Und hab mir, ich glaube, vor, weiß ich nicht, irgendwann nochmal angeschaut, dieses Omni-Graffle, was ja so die Alternative, die wahrscheinlich bekanntere Alternative zu Things ist.
Nee, Omni-Graffle ist das Sketching-Programm. Du meinst Omni-Focus.
Omni-Focus, genau.
Ja, aber Omni-Focus ist dann halt schon wirklich der 16-Tonner.
Genau, ist der 16-Tonner, das hab ich dann auch festgestellt. Und für mich funktionieren To-Do-Apps einfach überhaupt nicht.
Also Omni-Focus ist auch keine To-Do-App.
Ja, genau. Und ich bin aber halt immer wieder, hier wurde auch gerade schon Getting Things Done erwähnt, das Buch, was ich selber nicht gelesen hab. Ich hab aber mal so ein Stück YouTube-Video von einem Typ da gesehen, was ganz interessant ist, also dass man eben seine Taster irgendwie runterbrechen soll. Und bin irgendwann mal so auf diese Bullet-Journal-Community gestoßen. Sagst du das was? Ja, es ist eigentlich nichts anderes als eine große To-Do-Liste, die man nicht in sein digitales Teil, sondern eher in einem physischen Buch wirklich hat. Und fand das irgendwie ganz cool, weil ich früher auch immer wirklich so mit einer Agenda gearbeitet hab, einfach um To Do's und Termine festzulegen. Aber das hat halt irgendwann nicht mehr funktioniert, weil du schleppst natürlich nicht ständig deinen Kalender mit dir rum. Also hast du deine To Do's nicht dabei, weil der Kalender zu groß ist. Das war mir halt irgendwann zu viel geraffelt. Und hab dann ein Notizbuch gehabt, wo das so drin war. Und selbst das war dann irgendwann so, es war zu viel Aufwand. Und bin jetzt umgestiegen auf, also ich versuche halt wirklich so, mir für eine Woche Ziele zu setzen, was ich irgendwie erreichen muss. Und halt tagsüber auch noch, vor allen Dingen, wenn ich von zu Hause arbeite, so meine To Do's runterzuschreiben. Und was ich halt jetzt gemacht habe, ist vor allem Apple Notes zu benutzen. Ich hab da ein Template, weil es synchronisiert sich ja auch auf allen Geräten. Ich hab ja, ich hab da ein privates MacBook, was natürlich nicht denselben Inhalt hat wie mein Arbeits-Macbook, weil ich das irgendwie trennen möchte. Und ich hab mein Telefon. Und ich hab irgendwie meine Wochenübersicht, was ich so für Dinge einfach erledigen will auf dem Apple Notes. Und kann dann einfach schön meine To Do's abhaken und sie verschwinden vor allem nicht. Also als ich halt wirklich dann noch sehe, ah ja, irgendwie diese Woche schon eine ganze Menge, naja, naja doch, schon eine ganze Menge geschafft. Also es ist halt einfach so ein bisschen so befriedigend. Und macht mir dann halt wirklich, wenn ich zu Hause bin, da weiß ich einfach, dass ich gerne mal den Fokus verliere, was ich so zu tun habe, wirklich so eine To Do Liste für einen Tag. Und sitz dann da und hake die einfach ab. Weil es super befriedigend ist, seine Liste abzuhaken. Und es ist halt so das, wo ich jetzt mittlerweile merke, dass dieses System für mich halt gut funktioniert, diese Wochenübersicht zu haben, was in meinem Apple Notes drin ist. Und wenn ich zu Hause bin oder irgendwo bin, dann mach ich mir im Zweifelsfall einen kleinen Post-It und schreib da meine Tages-To Do's einfach auf. Und dann hab ich halt auch, also ich hab diese Wochenübersicht halt auch noch mal in kleiner Buchform, damit ich einfach so, wenn mir Sachen kommen, sie halt gleich wegschreiben kann. Und wenn man einfach keinen Bock aufs Telefon hat und hab dann halt sogar noch so, dass ich immer meine mini Post-Its dabei hab für Dinge, die ich mal machen muss, aber keine Ahnung wann. Also wird halt ein Post-It da irgendwo reingeklatscht und wenn ich in die Woche dann plättere, seh ich das und denk mir so, ah ja genau, ich wollte mir überlegen, ob ich eine neue Sonnenbrille kaufe. Ist halt super, ich arbeite dann echt wirklich so, ich arbeite total gern papierbasiert halt, weil das richtig gut für mich funktioniert.
Manchmal möchte man sich auch einfach ein Post-It Note irgendwo in die Software reinkleben.
Ich hab häufig irgendwie mal ein Post-It Note an meinem Telefon, weil ich weiß, dass ich dieses olle Telefon mitnehme. Hier hinten ist ja so viel Platz drauf, Post-It Note drauf geklatscht, nehme ich mit. Super. Oder hier auf den...
Ja, mit dem Post-It Note passen mehr Post-It Notes hin.
Wozu? Ich hab ja hier dieses MacBook 15 Zoll Pro.
Gibt's da auch welche drauf?
Also die linke Seite, da steht, liegt häufig meine Stulle und auf der rechten Seite habe ich häufig Post-It Note kleben.
Das Stullendrett.
Komm, also du hast hier so viel Platz und morgens, finde ich, kann man da einfach mal schön... Nicht die Nutella-Stulle ist nicht zu empfehlen, aber der Rest, den kann man da drauflegen.
Ja, tatsächlich bin ich ja auch großer Fan von der aktuellen Iteration der Notes App. Ich benutze sie zwar nicht als To Do Liste, sondern tatsächlich als Notes App, aber habe auch mit großer Freude festgestellt, dass da so dieses Templating oder beziehungsweise, dass man dann irgendwie jetzt auch den Titel setzen kann, der dann auch da erscheint und es nicht einfach nur die erste Zeile ist und so.
Das ist super.
Ich benutze die auch sehr gerne tatsächlich.
Ich habe das quasi wirklich auch in der iCloud und habe dann da irgendwie halt so einen Weekly-Order, wo das einfach alles drin ist. Dann habe ich halt auch so projektmäßig oder weiß ich nicht, ich habe Mailing-Listen. Wenn ich dann doch mal sehe, dass ich mir, wie jetzt gesagt, irgendwie was über CSS mal dann doch wieder anlesen möchte, dann habe ich halt so eine To-Read-Liste und dann kann ich da einfach durchgehen, mir einen Artikel rausklauben und durchlesen und dann abhaken oder auch wirklich rauslöschen. Also es ist, die aktuelle Iteration gefällt mir auch sehr gut. Wohingegen ich mit den Reminders halt nicht klarkomme. Das ist so ein hässliches Endline. Entschuldigung, das ist leider wirklich unbrauchbar.
Ja, die finde ich auch gut. Ich benutze ja immer noch so für, wenn ich mal eine Taskliste brauche, die ich so abhake, bin ich ja immer noch bei Wunderliste. Obwohl das ja jetzt auch so Software ist, die eher in der Kategorie Abandonware zu bezeichnen ist. Denn nachdem Microsoft die ja gekauft hat, haben sie ja beschlossen, das machen wir jetzt nicht weiter. Und machen eine eigene To-Do-Liste.
Nein, es ist doch wieder das, wo wir vorhin schon darüber gesprochen haben, mit Skype. Also gestern musste ich Skype mal wieder öffnen. Und es war so der Moment, schon als ich damals gehört habe, Microsoft kauft Skype. Und ich dachte so, na schön, danke. Und heute war wirklich so der Moment. Ich saß vor diesem Rotzding und konnte diese UI einfach nicht mehr bedienen, weil sie mir nichts gesagt hat, was sie da...
Also das geht gar nicht. Was ist eigentlich gerade unser Thema? Sind wir noch bei To Do oder sind wir jetzt bei Mac Apps allgemein, die uns gefallen oder frustrieren?
Gibt's da eine Trennung?
Na ja, klar.
Also To Do ist ein eigenes Universum.
Na ja, To Do ist ein eigenes Universum und man kann da jetzt...
Die ganze restliche Sendung davon.
Aber ich kann ja mal anders fragen, falls du nicht weiter darüber reden möchtest, was nicht schön ist. Aber vielleicht gibt es ja sonst noch so Software, die...
Oh, der Blick.
Kannst du den mal bitte in Audi umsetzen?
Ja, Kopa ist auch eine super Sache gewesen, aber ich liebe meinen Sublime Text Editor, weil das ist dieses Ding, was bei mir eigentlich permanent offen ist. Da fliegt alles rein, was ich so machen muss. Ich kann den Rechner zuklappen, in der Regel verschwindet die Sache. Manchmal verschwindet auch das aus diesem Cache. Aber es ist so dieses, es kann halt immer offen sein, du kannst deinen Text schnell reinhacken. Wenn ich irgendwie E-Mails schreiben muss, mach ich das lieber da drin. Es ist so dieses, ich hab auch, bevor ich Notes genutzt hab, in der Tat mir mit Sublime irgendwie einfach ungespeichert da die Sachen reingeschrieben. Es ist halt so ein... Ja, genau. Das ist Sublime, nicht nur zum Coden, auch für alles andere.
Aber ist das zum Coden besonders gut?
Ja, ich hab das...
Auch wenn ich da...
Kommt drauf an, was man macht. Ich hab ja ne Mischung, wenn ich...
Diese Modulinstallation ist irgendwie völlig unklar. Für mich ist in letzter Zeit immer entscheidend, kann ich eine beliebige CSV-Datei damit visualisieren? Die Antwort ist meistens nein.
Was heißt denn bei dir visualisieren? Bei mir ist visualisieren eine Grafik.
Naja, beim CSV gibt's... Das Mindeste wäre schon mal ein Syntax-Highlighting. Das würde mir schon mal sehr weiterhelfen. Die mehr advanceden CSV-Module in Texteditoren stellen auch richtig Spalten dar, wo du dann die Spalten verschieben kannst, sodass du schon fast in so einem Excel-Modus bist.
Das ist doch wirklich eine sehr spezielle Anforderung. Das ist halt ein Texteditor, kein CSV-Editor. Musst du ja ein Excel installieren, wenn du dir ein CSV-Programm anpediert.
Ein CSV ist ein Textformat.
Ja, aber du benutzt das...
Syntax-Highlighting ist ja wohl nicht so viel verlangt.
Nee, das ist nicht so viel verlangt.
Zeig mir mal für deinen bekloppten Sublime-Editor.
Das ist gar nicht mein beklopptes, ich benutze ja Wim.
Ach so, du benutzt Wim. Wim kann das bestimmt, aber Sublime, zumindest diese Module, die ich gefunden habe, sind halt alle so verboten. Die wollen halt, dass das Komma auch immer ein Komma ist. Wenn er mal ein Semikolon ist, geht das nicht.
Ich richte jetzt nicht über Sublime, aber an eines CSV-Moduls.
Nein, ruhig auch nicht.
Sublime ist super. Ich mag den selber sehr gerne. Ich hab den in letzter Zeit auch mehr zum Programmieren benutzt. Ich finde diese Preview, die man da recht sieht, extrem hilfreich. Aber vor allem ist er schnell. Also für mich ist auch immer entscheidend, dass die Dinger mit großen Dateien wenig Probleme haben.
Das fand ich auch super spannend zu sehen, mit wie großen Dateien Sublime wirklich noch umgehen kann. Also ich hatte ja das Problem, als ich das Projekt mit der Deutschen Nationalbibliothek gemacht habe, dass dann eben mal so Dateien ankamen, die irgendwie so im Gigabyte-Bereich waren. Und da war es bei Sublime wenigstens so, hey, ich zeig dir schon mal was, guck mal hier. Versuche jetzt vielleicht nicht drinnen zu scrollen, aber guck mal, so sieht es aus. Ich bin dann halt auch auf, ich glaube, ich bin auf Wim oder auf Emacs dann wieder umgestiegen, dafür weiß ich gar nicht. Ich glaube, ich bin auf Emacs dann umgestiegen, um einige von den ganz großen zu öffnen, weil die ja das Lazy Loading da drin haben, was dann okay war. Aber was ich bei Sublime auch super cool finde, dass du einfach und schnell dieses Multi-Line-Cursor einfügen hast, dieses Multiple-Cursor.
Das können aber mittlerweile so ziemlich alle freshen Texteditoren.
Ja, aber ich finde so, vielleicht weil ich Sublime auch schon viel zu, also wirklich sehr lange nutze, ist das halt so drin.
Ich benutze das?
Vor allem zum Beispiel eben, wenn ich mit Daten arbeite.
Also was kannst du das Feature mal genauer beschreiben, was das...
Dass du mehr als einen Cursor in deiner Datei hast an unterschiedlichen Stellen.
Ja, aber wie mache ich das?
Und du kannst das machen, indem du, ich glaube, Command und auf die Stelle drückst.
Ah, dann kann man an verschiedenen Stellen dasselbe reinschreiben.
Aber das geht ja noch viel krasser, ne?
Wow, das ist ja ganz cool.
Also ich weiß nicht, bei TextMate kann das und ich würde vermuten, dass das da bleiben auch kann. Du kannst ja dann auch nach Patterns suchen und dann setzt er dir überall den Cursor, wo das Pattern auftaucht. Du willst ja nicht von Hand klicken.
Das stimmt. Und du hast auch dieses Highlighting von den Sachen, die du gerade ausgewählt hast, von einem Pattern. Das ist halt wirklich... Ich liebe dieses Ding.
Die Cursor kommen ja alle sogar gleichzeitig bewegen.
Das ist ja wohl Späßwäters mäßig.
Also das ist für mich wirklich so die Offenbarung an...
Was wollen die eigentlich haben hier?
Das ist gar nicht so viel.
War das nicht auch 49 Dollar mal gewesen?
Oh wow, die haben eine neue Webseite. Krass, schön.
Also ich hab ja auch lange Zeit...
80 Dollar. Ja, aber das sind sie wert, würde ich meinen.
Ich hab ja auch schon viele Editoren so durch über die Jahre und Sublime hatte ich auf jeden Fall auch mal eine Weile. Und irgendwann bin ich eigentlich nur davon weg, weil ich mir in den Kopf gesetzt hatte, dass mein Editor im Terminal und auf dem Server genauso auszusehen hat wie lokal, damit ich mich überall gleich bewege sozusagen und keine Umstellung hab. Und dann war nur noch die Frage Wim oder Emacs und dann war es der Wim. Und seitdem bin ich halt ein Wimmer, obwohl ich für so eine Sachen wie du sie gerade beschrieben hast. Also Wim kann ja nicht Multi-Cursor, soweit ich weiß, aber zumindest Block-Edit und so weiter. Aber wenn ich so eine Sachen mache, dann mach ich halt den Text-Mate auf, weil der im Prinzip auch dann in diesem Multi-Cursor ein bisschen advanceder ist zur Datenmassage oder wenn man mal so einen Jason gerade rücken muss oder irgendwas. Aber im Prinzip die Anforderung war halt, ich will auch auf dem Server einen Editor haben, mit dem ich genauso gut klarkomme. Und dann ist der Sublime irgendwann wieder verschwunden von meiner Platte. Aber ich hab ihn auch lange Zeit sehr gemocht.
Ja, auf dem Server nutze ich halt immer nur noch den Nano. Das ist das einzige.
Ja, ich hab halt für mein Programmierzeug halt auch super viele Extensions, nicht super viele, aber so einige am Start, die ich dann eben natürlich auf dem Server hab.
Ja, also ich mach da ja relativ wenig, aber dazu kommen wir ja später nochmal. Aber das ist also wirklich so Sublime toll. Also um da vielleicht nochmal dazu zu sagen, ich nutz Sublime nicht ausschließlich zum Coden mit JavaScript, sondern in Kooperation mit dem Webstorm von JetBrains. Und den mag ich schon auch sehr gern, aber ich merk halt so manchmal ist es halt nicht die fette Idee, die du da sitzen haben willst, sondern den leichtfüßigen, schluffigen... Genau, aber ich find auch Webstorm ist irgendwie ein schönes Stück Software, wo ich eigentlich jetzt auch bisher immer alle Subscriptions erneuert habe, was ich es wirklich gut find.
So, weitere Lieblingsprogramme? Oder wollen wir nochmal hier auf unsere Notizen zurückkraten?
Also ein Programm, das echt... Immer wenn mir Leute so auf den Bildschirm gucken, wenn ich so meinen Computer bediene, dann gibt es immer so eine Frage, wie hast du denn das gerade gemacht? Wie hast du denn das Fenster dahin geschoben und so? Und ich benutze, habe ich auch schon mal hier erwähnt, aber es gibt ja auch neue Hörer, DeVille. Also hier für Letty, die neben mir sitzt, da kann ich dann halt sagen, hier, mach das Fenster mal nach links oben, nach rechts oben, dahin, dahin, pack's in die Mitte, pack's dahin, mach's Fullscreen und hab halt so Shortcuts oder ganz links halbe Seite, links oben, also ich hab hier so Presets, wo ich mir so Fenster einfach hinarangieren kann, die ich so per Shortcut habe. Da gibt's verschiedenste Tools für, ich hab schon ein paar probiert, über das, was hängen geblieben ist, was schon immer funktioniert hat und genau das macht, was ich gerne hätte. Gerade so diese Shortcut-Definition und so. Das ist eine der Sachen, die ich immer sofort installiere, wenn irgendwie Clean Install ansteht, weil ohne das wär's inarisch. Gibt's auch auf Windows mittlerweile.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich damit arbeiten könnte, aber was ich sehr, sehr genieße, ist das ja seit High Sierra gibt's ja nun endlich. Das ist ja wirklich manchmal absurd, wie lange man auf so was warten muss. Aber jetzt kannst du ja endlich mal das Window Resizing auf dem Mac ordentlich machen, indem du halt so Funktionen hast, wie du klickst auf den Rand, machst einen Doppelklick auf den Rand, und dann expandiert sich das Fenster halt maximal nach rechts oder nach links oder nach oben oder nach unten. Das geht auch auf der Ecke. Du kannst sogar mit Option den Rand nehmen und dann...
Aber ich klicke halt nicht, ne? Ich mach halt nur Shortcuts und das...
Ja, aber ich will es ja dann auch irgendwie in dem Moment eben so haben. Mir geht es meistens nur um ein Fenster, dass ich jetzt irgendwie alle Fenster...
Nee, das ist ja nicht für alle Fenster, aber ich sag mal, ich will jetzt gerade zwei Brausefenster nebeneinander haben. Ich mach zwei Fenster auf, sag hier Shortcut du nach links, Shortcut du nach rechts und dann sind die genau 50% geteilt.
Woher weiß er, welche beiden Fenster er nehmen soll, wenn da mehrere Fenster sind?
Apfel, Tilde und dann Shortcut, Apfel, Tilde, andere Shortcut. Also ich manage nicht mehrere Fenster gleichzeitig mit diesen Shortcuts, sondern es gibt Presets, die ich mir so eingerichtet habe, wo ich üblicherweise Fenster hinschieben will, zum Beispiel vier Terminals aufmachen. Die will man dann halt irgendwie schön natürlich maximal aufgeteilt. Hab ich mir so einen Shortcut für gemacht, für links oben, rechts oben, links unten, rechts unten und kann halt beliebige Fenster halt an die entsprechende Position, wo ich sie gerne hätte, hin.
Also du hast halt einen Shortcut für dieses Fenster ein Viertel groß machen und links oben hauen. So 1, 2, 3, 4. Das heißt, für jede spezifische Fenstergröße plus Positionierung brauchst du einen einzigen Shortcut.
Naja, es gibt halt einfach, ich hab so drüber nachgedacht, was benutze ich eigentlich die ganze Zeit oder was will ich, ja? Und dann bin ich auf so ein kleines Set Shortcuts gekommen, nämlich einmal diese Viertel-Aufteilung, horizontal halbiert, also zum Beispiel so Log-Fenster von zwei Servern oder so, oder eben halbiert vertikal getrennt. Und dann hab ich noch so den Browser-Mode, nenn ich den, der ist sozusagen, naja, vielleicht zwei Drittel des Screens in der Mitte als Fenster und einmal von oben bis unten voller Browser-Größe sozusagen, aber da ist noch links und rechts noch ein bisschen Platz daneben. Und das sind so, und Fullscreen natürlich, also ganzen Bildschirm ausfüllen bitte. Das sind eigentlich die Shortcuts, die ich habe, mit denen ich seit Jahren arbeite und wenn dann halt immer so die Fenster so akkurat an ihre Stelle fliegen, dann auch so die Studenten natürlich, die sehen das ja dann am Projektor relativ häufig. Und ja, weiß nicht, also ich mag bessere oder tollere oder was auch immer für Tools geben. Ich kann nur sagen und hier sind wir bei diesen Empfehlungen von Dingen, die Leute sich gekauft haben und ausprobiert haben und gut befunden haben. Das ist was, was ich seit Jahren benutze und glücklich damit bin.
Du hast mich im Übrigen sehr unglücklich mit dem Alfred gemacht. Das habe ich, das fand ich nie so gut wie die Spotlight-Geschichte.
Wie Spotlight? Macht doch unterschiedliche Sachen.
Aber ich habe Alfred hauptsächlich für die Suche eigentlich genutzt. Da fand ich die Suchergebnisse immer so. Ich weiß, dass ich es früher auch mal genutzt habe.
Aber Alfred benutzt das nicht Spotlight für die Suche?
Die Ergebnisse waren signifikant schlechter.
Hast du so als Appstart?
Natürlich, ich bin viel zu faul irgendwas. Also bei mir ist immer nur Command-Lehrtaste und dann war das irgendwie.
Aber das lernt doch auch nach deinem... Ich benutze das ja auch hauptsächlich mittlerweile für die Clipboard-History. Also das ist nämlich auch ein wiederkehrendes Productivity-Tool, ohne dass ich nicht mehr leben möchte. Clipboard-History. Wer das nicht hat, der lebt nicht.
Also mit Clipboard-Histories habe ich so meinen Krampf. Das ist ja in Launchbar auch drin und das ist immer das erste Feature, was ich abschalte, weil ich irgendwie sonst nicht mehr klarkomme.
Ich habe halt einen dedizierten Shortcut ja dafür. Das heißt, das ist jetzt nicht in den normalen Suchen mit drin. Und ich weiß nicht, ich kann nicht mehr ohne. Ich habe das mir auf Apfel Alt V gelegt, also quasi alternativ pasten.
Dann kommt ein Menü mit den letzten 20 Einträgen oder was?
Nein, ich habe drei Monate Clipboard-History und es ist halt Volltext-Suche. Ich fange einfach an zu tippen, so was weiß ich, Githa und dann kommen die Links oder was auch immer ich da gepastet hatte aus Githa.
Also alle URLs, die man mal so...
Oder alles, was man so gepastet hat. Und dadurch, dass es so eine super schnelle Volltext-Suche ist, ich finde halt auch in kürzester Zeit, dass Alfred, weil Tim hier auf den Screen zeigt und sagt, ich soll das posten.
Also in Alfred ist die Clipboard hier.
Ich benutze die von Alfred App und dafür muss man Alfred dann halt kaufen, nämlich das Powerpack, das ist nicht in der Gratisversion drin. Kostet 19 Pfund.
Muss ich halt nochmal gucken, ob Launchbar das so hat, wie du das gerade beschrieben hast.
Also ich würde vermuten...
Zwischen-Ablage-Verlauf aktivieren.
Das würde mich eigentlich wundern, wenn Launchbar das nicht genauso drin hätte.
Kapazität, bist du eine Woche?
Bei Alfred kann man auch sagen, was dann da drin liegen soll. Also ob man auch Bilder und alle möglichen Binär-Dateien für Monate aufheben will. Ich muss mal gucken, wie ich das eingestellt habe.
Ah, Clip-Merge, das war immer das, was mich so genervt hat.
Ah ja, das habe ich auch ausgeschaltet, das Clip-Merge. Das finde ich auch Schrott.
Und man kann bestimmte Programme auch nur ignorieren bei Launchbar.
Genau, kann man da auch sagen, Keychain, bitte nicht in die History.
Genau, sowas.
Ja, eben weil diese Vergänglichkeit des Clipboards ist ja auch ein Feature.
Was ist ja geil, wie der das wieder abschließt.
Also ich habe drei Monate Plain Text. Du kannst bei Alfred sagen, drei Monate Plain Text, Images für 24 Stunden und irgendwelche anderen File Lists auch für 24 Stunden. Aber ich speichere eigentlich nur Text in der History.
Ich werde das mal testen.
Also ich finde, das hat wirklich sehr meine Computernutzung verändert und optimiert. Weil immer wenn ich an den Computern sitze, so beim Kollegen mal kurz was machen und dann ah, du hast keine Clipboard History. Und dann fängt dieses Jonglieren an. Also ok, wir kopieren erstmal das aus dem Fenster in das Fenster und dann kopieren wir das in das Fenster und dann immer so schön perlenkettenmäßig und das muss man da nicht machen, das ist super.
Da fällt mir auch gerade wieder ein, dass ich irgendwie dass ich schon wieder vergessen habe, was ich früher immer benutzt habe. Verdammte Axt. Jetzt wo wir gerade über so Sachen reden, ich hör mir gerade wieder ein, dass ich schon seit Jahren mal wieder zu was zurückkehren wollte, was es irgendwie immer noch gibt. Und jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr, wie es heißt.
Ich weiß nur, was es tut.
Es gibt ja aus der alten Mac OS Zeit, das war ja echt eine Hochphase dieser kleinen Tools. Vielleicht weißt du das noch, wie es heißt. Es hat bestimmt ganz naheliegenden Namen. Und zwar klingt sich das in den Safe-Dialog rein. Weil bis heute ist ja das Verhalten von diesem Safe-Dialog in OS X oder Mac OS oder wie auch immer, brain dead. Also du startest, machst zum Beispiel ein Dokument auf.
Doppelklick.
Dann sagst du, du plizier mal, so Safe-S. Was würde man dann erwarten, welcher Ordner einem angeboten wird? Der, in dem das Ding vorher auch war. Nee, das ist dann irgendwie der letzte Ordner. Der Chat hilft. Default-Folder. Mal gucken, ob es das noch gibt. Und Default-Folder, genau das war's. Default-Folder hat mich jahrelang begleitet.
Gibt es das noch?
Ja, es gibt es immer noch. Ich hatte so ein bisschen Angst, dass ich das nicht gut integriert. Das muss ich aber jetzt echt mal wieder ausprobieren. Default-Folder war unter macOS aus dem alten, war das wirklich der totale Segen. Weil du halt einfach mal sehr gut bestimmen kannst, welche Ordner dir da angeboten werden und was sozusagen. Ich wechsle die ganze Zeit meine Ordner, ich wechsle die ganze Zeit meine Programme. Ich speicher mit. Wenn ich jetzt so Project Change habe, mit jetzt kümmere ich mich um, dann arbeite ich halt mit bis zu 5 oder 10 verschiedenen Programmen da dran. Da muss der Omni-Outliner ran, da muss irgendwie eine Textverarbeitung, Melle muss irgendwie was reinschreiben, Pages und Numbers und Pipaponen, Akkorden und Bilder bearbeiten und keine Ahnung, was man halt immer gerade so macht. Aber alle müssen irgendwie in diesen scheiß Ordner ran und jedes Mal musst du immer wieder in den Finder irgendwie dieses scheiß Teil da reindrängen, weil du es einfach nicht findest. Und bei der ganzen Ordnermarchie auch viel zu tief und weit ist, als dass man da mal eben von Hand durch marschieren könnte.
Aber dieser Rapper da, den er da um den Finder rum bastelt, der sieht jetzt schon auch ein bisschen arg hässlich aus.
Ja, was meinst du jetzt, bei Default-Folder? Ja, das war nämlich immer so ein bisschen meine Angst und deswegen habe ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht ausprobiert. Aber ich werde das jetzt einfach mal probieren. Mal gucken, ob es irgendwie, weil es ist einfach unerträglich.
Dann machen wir einen schönen RPFS-Schnaps-Schuss vorher.
Ja, kann schon sein. Naja, aber das sind so diese kleinen Dinger. Noch so ein kleines Ding, wenn man noch Platz hat, gerade so für Laptop-User, finde ich das immer super. Das benutze ich auch schon seit Ewigkeiten. Habe ich vor ein paar Wochen wieder reingeschmissen. Heißt Bwannadik. Bwannadik, B-W-A-N-A-D-I-K. Guck grad mal, was hier die Original... Ach, da gibt es sogar noch einen Twitter-Account dazu. We don't wanna know, ist das...
Nee.
Ah ja, genau hier. Das hat nämlich dieser John Schilling geschrieben. John Schilling war der Typ, der damals der Erste war, der so diese Bluetooth-Fähigkeit der Macs benutzt hat. Das war die erste Software, mit der du deine Handys ordentlich ans Telefon koppeln konntest und schon so Sachen machen konntest, wie du gehst mit deinem Telefon aus dem Raum, die Bluetooth-Verbindung reißt ab und er macht automatischen Log-Screen und so was. Und die Zeit. Und Valadik ist so ein super Beispiel für so ein Programm, das einfach mal extrem wenig tut. Das macht nämlich nichts anderes als oben in deiner Menu Bar so einen roten oder grünen Punkt anzuzeigen. Und wenn der Punkt grün ist, dann hast du Internet. Weißt du, das ist so was ganz Einfaches. Und das ist so cool, weil du weißt, kannst du auch mal reingehen, dann weißt du auch mal gleich deine externe IP-Adresse und so weiter.
Ich erinnere mich sogar daran.
An das Programm? Ja, das funktioniert einfach. Und das ist so einfach. Und das ist so hilfreich. Weil wie oft bist du schon in irgendeinem blöden Café, starst du drauf, so warum lädt das jetzt nicht und so. Und dann hat sich dein scheiß Rechner wieder in irgendeinem blöden Hotspot eingebucht. Und du hast eigentlich kein Netz. Und bis du das dann merkst, so vergeht so viel Zeit. Und wenn dich einfach dieser kleine grüne Punkt nicht anstarrt, sondern rot sagt, dann weißt du halt so, ah okay.
Ich muss mich mal wieder um die Arbeit kümmern. Ich wollte gerade, mir wollte gerade ein Betty über die Lippen rollen, weil ich gerade vor kurzem erst Betty wieder gesehen hatte. Nee, hier. Raum... Raumagentur Betty. Letty Blue. Äh, weil du ja gerade so Alfred weggebürstet hast. Ähm, hast du denn, also... So, wenn ich den nur als Application Launcher benutzen würde, wär mir das vielleicht jetzt auch zu wenig, ne? Wobei das für mich super funktioniert, aber ich benutze es ja zum Beispiel auch tagtäglich um in Dash nach Sachen nachzugucken.
Dash nutze ich nicht mehr.
Alles klar.
Ja, Dash ist ein Programm, womit man alle APIs irgendwie sich offline legen kann.
Wieso gibt es was besseres?
Ich muss ehrlich gestehen...
Du weißt alles auswendig.
Logisch, immer.
Ich tippe jetzt E, R, R lang, Application, und dann kannst du hier sagen tipp und dann bist du gleich da.
Genau, aber wenn ich mit was arbeite, ich arbeite meistens halt dann doch mit der Webseite. Muss ich gestehen, dass ich häufig über die Mozilla-Seite gehe.
J, S, oder was habe ich hier nicht installiert?
Ich weiß, dass es das gibt und ich fand es aber...
Also ich muss sagen, diese Mozilla-Integration, die ist auch nicht so gut wie alle anderen Programmierfragen, die ich da bisher drin hatte, weil das mit... Hier kannst du halt dann auch wirklich in die Funktionen und so reinspringen und das ist schon sehr cool. Weil jetzt kann ich hier bei Lists bin ich, also das Fenster ist jetzt gerade noch offen und kann jetzt hier auch noch sowas, was war das? All Any, keine Ahnung. Also diese ganze Completion ist da halt mit drin und das ist wirklich super schnuffig. Und ja, als ich jetzt hier mit JavaScript auch wieder zu tun hatte, dachte ich auch, alles klar, geil, nicht immer durch diese Webseite mehr andern, die auch nicht immer die übersichtlichste ist. Aber leider ist die Dash-Integration genauso wenig übersichtlich.
Vielleicht hab ich es deswegen auch wieder aufgegeben.
Aber ich muss sagen, also Ruby, Erlang, R, Go und so, das ist eigentlich alles ziemlich cool gewesen da drin. Oder ist. Nicht nur gewesen, ist immer noch cool.
Vielleicht schaue ich es mir wieder mal an.
SQL zum Beispiel auch, weil du gerade hier die MySQL-Seite auf hast.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die ist es auch zum, also hier in der, weil du sie gerade siehst, ich hab bei MySQL häufig in der Doku halt rumgebraust, was so drin steht. Weil ich noch nicht so richtig sicher war, nach was ich genau suche. Und ich hatte immer das Gefühl, dass das bei Dash nicht ganz so gut geht, weil dir diese Seitenstruktur manchmal fehlte.
Da weiß ich aber nicht, ob ich einfach nur zu blöd war. Naja, zum Beispiel suche ich öfters mal, wie heißt das? Data-Types. Und ich glaube, das ist nämlich so ein Beispiel, wo du das gerade so sagst, wo ich auch jedes Mal nicht das finde, so in dieser Dash-Doku. Und ich weiß, aber es gibt eine Seite, irgendwas mit Data-Types. Und dann findet man die nicht. Aber zum Beispiel, was mir öfters eher passiert ist, ich weiß zwar prinzipiell, wie ein Insert-Statement funktioniert, aber dann willst du halt doch nochmal nachgucken, wie so die Feinheiten von und so weiter. Und da dann mal so schnell hinzuspringen, also das geht mir schneller aus den Fingern, Abfüll Space, SQL, Insert als Browser, Google.
Okay, ich hab halt meistens dann, wenn ich an einem Thema arbeite, habe ich dann eh schon die Doku auf. Weil ich, also wie jetzt mit dem MySQL, da musste ich einige Sachen nachschauen. Und hatte dann eh die SQL-Doku auf und bin dann da kurz hin und her gesprungen. So das ist für mich gar nicht so.
Wonach hätte ich suchen müssen? Data-Lehrzeichen-Types. Nein, gibt's nicht.
Ja, und da ist dann immer so, also das kann gut sein, dass ich deswegen Dash auch nicht mehr benutzt habe. Weil wenn irgendwie, also ich hab halt schon immer viel mit MySQL und JavaScript halt rumprökeln müssen.
Ja, also ich war auch nie ein großer Dash-Fan, bis ich dann, also ja, rausgefunden hab, dass für die Programmiersprachen, mit denen ich jetzt gerade dann irgendwie viel zu tun hatte, dass da die Integration besonders gut war und dann hat's halt mit Alfred dann auch wiederum Spaß gemacht und so weiter.
Ich hab's sogar hier noch drauf, aber wofür ich's halt wirklich gut finde ist, wenn du dann doch mal wieder den Genuss hast, mit der Deutschen Bahn zu verreisen und eh kein Internet. Dafür ist Dash halt wirklich super. Ich hab's halt selber nie gekauft, weil ich es nie so gut fand. Und dafür ist es dann aber so, dass ich mir denke, okay, es passiert wirklich nur alle paar Tage des, äh, alle paar Tage, alle paar Jahre, dass ich irgendwie im Zug wirklich arbeiten will, coden will und kein Internet habe. Genau, dass ich dann dafür dieses Backup von Dash irgendwie drauf habe. Aber ansonsten die Idee an sich finde ich super bei Dash. Die MySQL sieht wirklich rotz aus.
Wir können das ja zu gegebener Zeit auch fortsetzen, wenn ihr euch sozusagen noch weitere Programme bewertet. Ich glaube, das kommt immer gut an.
Ich muss mal auf meinem Arbeitsrechner explizit danach schauen, weil ich mein, da ich das jetzt so ein bisschen getrennt habe, Rechner, äh, Rechner und Rechner. Arbeit und privat. Pi mal Daumen. Da hab ich da natürlich andere Programme auch drauf.
Muss ich mal wirklich mal nachschauen.
Bevor wir zum nächsten größeren Themenkomplex kommen und wir gerade so in so einer kleinen Empfehlungs-Ecke sind. Ich hab ja noch eine kleine Empfehlung, die...
Online ist wirklich so eine Online-Shopping-Musik.
Dass das ohne Geld, ohne Geld ist. Komplett gratis.
Wie soll ich denn da meine Affiliate-Kohle kommen?
Affiliate-Kohle kommen.
Und zwar, ihr kennt das ja, ne? Man wacht so morgens auf und irgendwann ringt man sich dazu durch, doch mal so eine Nachrichtenseite aufzumachen und dann... Naja, dann kriegt man halt so die Welt von dieser einen Nachrichtenseite und dann, wenn man so richtig motiviert ist und noch nicht schlechte Laune hat und sowieso alles nicht mehr sehen will, dann klickt man vielleicht noch die nächste Nachrichtenseite an und nun mal, um sich so einen Vergleich, so einen Vergleichsüberblick zu holen, weil ja in unterschiedlichen Medien unterschiedliche Dinge wichtig sind. Und ich glaube, dann einen Tag habe ich mich über Spiel Online so aufgeregt, weil einfach da so viel Boulevard-Bullshit mittlerweile aufgetaucht und dann auch noch so Bundeswehr-Werbung und keine Ahnung was. Dann hat mir ein Kollege eine Webseite empfohlen, die heißt Newstral oder Newsstral. Und das ist so eine Nachrichtenübersichtseite, die ich irgendwie sehr schick gemacht finde, weil da von jedem Medium, erstmal auf der Übersichtseite, die Top 3 Schlagzeilen von diesem Medium sind, auch mit so Uhrzeit, dass man sieht, von wann sind die. Und dann sieht man auch mal auf einen Blick, was bei Spiegel, Welt, FAZ, NTV, Süddeutsche etc. gerade so wichtig ist. Und vor allen Dingen auch, wie die so unterschiedlich gewordet sind und formuliert. Was du vorhin schon meintest, Tim, mit so Fragestellungen im Artikelnamen und so. Und du merkst auch so den journalistischen Duktus. Einfach nur, wenn du die Schlagzeilen von den verschiedenen Medien zum gleichen Thema vielleicht durchliest. Das Schöne ist halt, wenn du keinen Account hast, dann kriegst du halt irgendwie die ganze Liste da. Du kannst ja halt auch einen Account machen mit genau dem Dashboard von deinen Lieblingsmedien. Die haben halt auch so Sachen wie Guardian und Washington Post und so. Das sind jetzt nicht nur deutsche Medien, sondern auch wirklich sehr viele andere. Nee, es ist einfach so Überblick. Wenn du deinen morgendlichen oder wann auch immer Nachrichten überblickst, was ist jetzt eigentlich gerade heiß in der Welt? Ja, nur viel slicker und ohne Google. Ich finde es sehr viel übersichtlicher tatsächlich. Also ich benutze das ganz gerne. Und wenn man sich einen Account macht und sich sein eigenes Dashboard da zusammenklickt, dann ist es einfach... Ich bin halt so ein... Ich mag so minimalistische Sachen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie Mac Surfer, nur mit ein klitzekleines bisschen mehr Grafikdesign oder Informationsdesign.
Ich finde die Themen sehr lustig. Technik, Wirtschaft, Sport, Blockchain, Auto, Kunst.
Country und Wässer, sag ich mal nur.
Ja, das ist halt gerade heiß in der Welt, was sollst du sagen, ne? Aber wie gesagt, einfach nur so, ne? Für Leute, die sich dafür interessieren, jetzt nicht nur in ihrem Hausmedium mal zu gucken, was so geht, sondern einfach so Überblick. Weil ich finde zum Beispiel Google News total unübersichtlich und total irgendwie komme ich mir da sehr stark in so einer Bubble vor von dem, was mir da so präsentiert wird. Ist, also wie gesagt, ist auch jetzt keine flammende Rede, sondern ich mag es einfach nur gerne. Und weil das auch kaum jemand kennt und ab und zu werde ich da auch mal drauf angesprochen. Was ist das?
Also das gibt es schon länger. Ich habe, glaube ich, auch den Typen mal kennengelernt. Das ist nämlich ein Deutscher, der das macht. Dieser Wieland-Lindental, der das irgendwie entwickelt hat. Ich glaube, der war irgendwann mal auf der Republika, da ist er irgendwie bei uns irgendwie rumgelaufen, haben wir irgendwie kurz miteinander gequatscht, irgendwie sowas. Da gab es das schon, da war das neu. Das muss jetzt so 5, 6 Jahre her sein. Und ja, interessant zu sehen, dass das noch gibt. Ich frage mich, was da so das Geschäftsmodell dahinter ist. Oder ob das sozusagen immer noch... Es ist irgendwie so eine merkwürdige Mischung aus Deutsch und Spanisch, ne? Das ist ja irgendwie alles, was default ist, ist es irgendwie auf Spanisch und schlechter Lokalisierung. Was mich so ein bisschen...
Bei mir steht alles auf Deutsch. Wo hast denn du da gerade aufgeklickt, dass du Spanisch bekommst?
Na, guck mal hier oben im Sucht.
Ja, aber wo hast du da rauf geklickt?
Ich hab nur gesagt, ermittel meinen Standort und zeig mir mal Nachrichten an, die hier um mich herum relevant sind.
Bei mir steht da Search.
Bei mir steht da Busca.
Vielleicht weiß er, dass ich so ein Fäbler habe für Spanisch.
Ja, bei mir bleibt es bei Search.
Search.
Das nur so als kleiner für den kleinen Nachrichtenstrahl.
Der Nachrichtenstrahl.
So, jetzt können wir wieder ein größeres Pferd aufräumen.
Letty wollte noch ein bisschen aus ihrem Leben berichten.
Aus dem Leben meiner Geistesgestörten.
Ähm, nee, ich hab, wie einige wahrscheinlich wissen, bin ich ja auch Entwicklerin, hab mich aber so direkt nie mit Server beschäftigen müssen, weil ich eher im Frontend und wenn Backend dann gebe ich ein Stück Code ab, sag ich mal. Um den wird sich liebevoll gekümmert. Ich muss mich um nichts weiteres kümmern. Also, einen Admin gab's immer in meinem Team. Da ich jetzt aber die leitliche Erfahrung machen musste, dass so ein Admin nicht immer da ist, wenn man ihn braucht, auch in so einem größeren Team nicht, ähm, war ich gezwungen, mich mal mit so Server-Zeugs auseinanderzusetzen. Am Anfang war ich halt so oh Gott, oh Gott, ich werd da alles kaputt machen. Und hab mir fürs erste auf Amazon irgendwie einen EC2-Instanz als Server und einen Datenbank-Server geklickt. Mussten allerdings relativ schnell feststellen, dass es keine gute Idee ist, bei einer anspruchsvolleren Datenbank auf Amazon zu setzen, weil der ganze Spaß kostet dich mal locker irgendwie 400 bis 500 Dollar im Monat. Weil die Datenbanken teuer sind bei denen.
Also wenn man sie im Performant haben will.
Genau, also um das Problem vielleicht da zu umreißen, die deutsche Nationalbibliothek hat so ein, zwei Datensätze, da kommen auch so ein, zwei Gigabyte zusammen. Also ich hab meine sehr abgespeckte Datenbank, ich glaube, immer noch auf acht Gigabyte von der Größe her. Und du willst natürlich, wenn Leute darauf suchen auch, dass sie zeitnah ein Ergebnis bekommen. Und dann irgendwie so die Anforderungen, so 16 Gigabyte RAM irgendwie zu haben. Und naja, das kostet bei Amazon, wenn es in Deutschland, dann halt auch ist relativ sehr viel Geld, sehr viel Geld.
Und kurze Zwischenfrage, macht ihr die Suche direkt auf der Datenbank oder benutzt ihr sowas wie Elastic Search?
Naja, hätte ich auch ganz gern, bis man dann, bevor wir bei, also es gab einen zu langen Prozess, die Kosten so häufig als, dass es mit zu viel Geld abgetan wurden. Und so eine Elastic Search, weil ich eben wie gesagt eigentlich kein Admin bin und nach wie vor kein Admin bin, hab ich halt nur geguckt, was das kostet, wenn man den Spaß irgendwo hostet. Und da war man ja schnell bei einem ähnlichen Preis. Und das war so der Moment, wo ich dachte, das wäre der Preis und es kam ungefähr ein bisschen bescheuert zurück, so nach dem Motto. Deswegen, eine Elasticsearch hätte sich auch für die Daten viel mehr geeignet. Aber aus Gründen durfte es dann nur was günstiges werden. Ob es günstig geworden ist, ist halt so eine andere Frage. Habt ihr denn quasi so meine ersten Schritte mit diesem AWS und Datenbank-Server gemacht? Und das lief irgendwie alles, wenn die Doku nicht so schallt. Also wenn ihr denkt, dass die Webseite von Amazon schon der letzte Rotz ist, dann schaut euch nie diese AWS-Seite an. Die ist so schlecht dokumentiert. Teilweise sind die Beispiele darin falsch und funktionieren nicht. Also da war wirklich so irgendwo zwischen yay, es funktioniert und Nervenzusammenbruch. Dieses Projekt wird nie im Leben irgendwo laufen. Also es war halt wirklich so natürlich immer alles so eng gestrickt, was die Zeitpläne angehen. Und wenn du dich mit Servern eigentlich nicht auskennst, ist das dann so, wo du denkst so, wenn ich das kaputt mache, da fliegt mir, weiß ich was, und alle gehen auf diesen Server und aahhh. Das hab ich aber irgendwie alles gelöst bekommen mit der AWS, mich auch in Engine X und System D-Services und so weiter reingefunkt. Also halt wirklich, also meine Anwendung hat einen Backend in Python und irgendwie mit Flux und PyMySQL und Frontend so typisches JavaScript-Geraffel plus irgendwelche Frameworks.
Ja, gute Zusammenfassung, Geraffel und irgendwelche Frameworks.
Anders kann man das ja nicht sagen.
Besser kann man das nicht auf den Punkt bringen.
Ich hatte da auch meine Frontend-Unterstützung, der war wirklich großartig, also ohne den wär dieses Projekt auch nie gelaufen. Deswegen weiß ich auch in der Tat dann gar nicht mehr, was alles da noch dazugekommen ist zu dem Geraffel. Und ja, hab ihn mit der AWS rumgespielt und da wird dir ja vieles auch abgenommen, worüber du dich bei einem Server dann doch wieder Gedanken machen musst. Auch so dieses Konzept, dass man Security Groups definieren kann in dem AWS, dass du wirklich sagst, dieser Datenbank-Server ist nur aus dieser Security Group erreichbar und nicht von außen, was ja irgendwie total super ist, aber dir wird halt viel mit einem Interface angeboten, was natürlich die Sache sehr stark vereinfacht. Da uns aber die Kosten irgendwann so ein bisschen naja, zu viel geworden sind nach zwei Monaten, verständlich. Aber halt so die Frage, okay, wir müssen da umziehen auf einen eigenen Server und hab von der IT in der Fachhochschule halt zwei Server zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen. Und war dann halt wieder so vor diesem, so jetzt hast du da zwei Server, das ist nicht wie bei der AWS, wo du im Zweifelsfall auf Shutdown löschen klickst, sondern das ist da so was Ernstes. Da war ich halt so voll so, oh Gott, wenn ich das jetzt hier in den Sand setze.
Da muss man dann mit dem Schraubenzieher vorm Rack stehen und die Dinger erstmal rausschrauben.
Naja, hoffentlich nicht.
Nee, und das war aber wirklich so, dass ich dann schon nochmal so ein bisschen mehr Angst hatte, da erst recht was kaputt zu machen.
Aber es waren jetzt keine virtualisierten Server, wir reden jetzt von richtigen...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, doch, doch, doch. Ich hab am Anfang gesagt so Server und dann meinte der IT-Fachs-Mensch, dann halt so zu mir, brauchst du einen Server-Server oder reichen dir virtuelle Server? Und dann hab ich gesagt, mir reichen eigentlich virtuelle Server, solange ich die und die Gegebenheiten da drauf hab und ich vor allem Root-Zugang bekomme. Ist mir das ja wurscht. Ja, und da hab ich halt zwei virtuelle Server für das eine Projekt bekommen. Eins, was wirklich auch getrennt ist für die Datenbank, was dann nur aus dem Internet...
Also ist das jetzt so ein virtueller Server, wo auch schon das OS schon drauf ist, also quasi nur eine virtuelle Maschine innerhalb eines OS?
Das weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Oder musstest du dein Betriebssystem noch selber einigen?
Das hat er gefragt und dann hab ich gesagt, würde ich gerne nicht, weil das war mir dann wirklich zu heiß, wo ich dann denke, also... Bei mir sieht das dann halt... Na ja, ein Ubuntu 16.04. Genau, das hab ich explizit genommen, weil ich das auf der AWS auch schon hatte. Also ich hab mich ebenso mit dem System D-Service dann so weit auseinandergesetzt, dass ich damit arbeiten konnte, weil vorher hatte ich glaube ich eine Debian-Version, wo ich irgendwie einmal im Club saß und dachte so, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, wer kennt sich denn mit diesen, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie die Services bei Debian hießen, um deinen...
Die Upstart.
Genau, um deinen Service halt einfach laufen zu lassen. Und ich hab da wirklich alles nach Anleitung gemacht. Das war davor.
Achso, du hast es erst mit den klassischen Tools...
Genau, ich hab's quasi mit dem Debian versucht und dachte mir so, boah ey, hallo, Entschuldigung, kann mir jemand helfen?
Die reden alle weg, ne? Aber wenn du System D sagst, dann fangen sie alle an zu schreien.
Und es war wirklich so, die zwei Leute, die da waren, die Filmezwerbern machen, meinten dann so, ja, ich könnte da mal drüber gucken, aber eigentlich willst du das nicht benutzen. Ich so, na geil, nochmal alles neu machen.
Das bei Linox ist ja nun auch nochmal extra speziell, weil die ja alle 2,5 Jahre ihr Start-up, Skript, was auch immer System geändert haben. Ich übertreibe jetzt, aber es gab da schon diverse Iterationen und keine war jetzt ein besonders großer Wurf. Deswegen ist dann immer so, uuuh.
Das hab ich bis dato noch nie so mitbekommen, aber das war dann das erste Mal, wo ich dachte, wenn das irgendwie läuft, dann wird dir schon jemand im Club helfen können. Na ja, die liefen alle davon. Und dann hab ich das da schon auf Ubuntu und ein System, die umgestellt und rumprobiert und das lief halt wirklich einfach. Ohne groß was tun zu müssen, das ist übertrieben, aber da hat ja auf jeden Fall Stack Overflow eine ganze Menge erzählen können. Und sonstige Dokumentationen. Das war halt echt super.
Kurze Frage noch. War das zufällig, weißt du ob das auf VM basierte, deine virtualisierten Server?
Weiß ich nicht genau. Das sieht man in den Packages, oder?
Nee, das solltest du aus der VM raus selber vielleicht gar nicht sehen unbedingt. Das hätten die dir vielleicht gesagt oder so.
Kann sein, dass es VM ist, aber weiß ich nicht so genau. Aber jedenfalls, die waren auch voll happy, weil sie sonst immer so Professoren oder Mitarbeiter bekommen, die dann sagen, ich könnte da mal was gebrauchen. Ich hab ihnen halt klar auch sagen können, die Ports müssen offen sein, der Rest muss zu sein. Und die waren schon so ein bisschen so, oh danke. Klare Anweisungen und nicht nur so ein ich bräuchte da das und jenes und unklare Spezifikationen.
Ich bräuchte da mal so ein Web-Server.
Genau, naja, hab ich ja wie gesagt zwei Server von denen bekommen. Einen schon explizit nur für die Datenbank, sodass der auch nur aus dem Internet erreichbar ist. Und nicht von außen, sodass dann natürlich nicht der MySQL-Port offen ist. Und halt der andere, der vom Internet und so weiter erreichbar halt ist. Ich hab dann erstmal angefangen mir dann irgendwie so auch das MySQL darauf zu installieren. Und das läuft auch alles ja ganz fein. Und ich mach mir mittlerweile auf GitHub Notizen, damit ich das eben reproduzieren kann, was ich da auch mache. Das ist ganz praktisch. Und bin dann auch über was gestoßen. Da war ich so voll geil, das geht. Dass man bei MySQL Nutzer einrichten kann, die explizit nur von einer Domain kommen dürfen, die dann wirklich Privilegien hat, wie zum Beispiel du darfst einfach nur ein Select-Statement ausführen. Und ich saß so davor und dachte mir so, boah ist das geil, du kannst einfach alles restriktieren. Da ging mir irgendwie kurz das Herz auf.
Aber Informationen wollen noch frei sein.
Schon? Die Deutsche Nationalbibliothek freut sich bestimmt, auch wenn Goethe auf einmal weitere Werke dazu bekommt. Aber das war nicht so ganz das Ziel. Da habe ich mich echt so darüber gefreut, dass man diese ganzen Rechte auch einfach mal restriktieren kann. Und dann habe ich auch noch geguckt, wie man dann natürlich hinbekommt, dass dein Server, der im Intranet ist, den anderen Server aus dem Intranet erreicht. Was musst du da noch an Einstellungen machen im MySQL? Das war wirklich so, wo ich mir dachte, boah, geil, ich komme mir voll wissend vor. Bis mir dann irgendjemand auch sagte, jeder Admin guckt auch nur auf Stackoverflow. Ich dachte, ja, trotzdem.
Außer wenn man Freebase benutzt, da gibt es nämlich nicht so viel. Nee, aber das stimmt auch nicht. Es gibt auch da Informationen zu.
Das Coole war auch so, dann der Application-Server, also habe ich dann auch alles eingerichtet, dass der Application-Server auch darauf zugreifen konnte. Dann auch Let's Encrypt und ein Nginx-Geraffel wieder gemacht. Aber was ich bis dahin noch nie genutzt habe, war halt IVV6. Weil natürlich die EFH auch IVV6-Adressen hat. Super toller Service, als auch natürlich die Adresse mit IVV6 hat. Wenn der Clemens jetzt hier wäre, der würde sich freuen.
Der freut sich remote. Hast du denn auch einen DNS-Record dafür, der auf die V6-Adresse zeigt, oder muss man die V6-Adresse von Hand eintreten?
Ja, ich dachte, das macht man so. Nee, also ich musste mich jetzt auch nicht... Ich musste halt auch nicht, also an den DNS-Einträgen musste ich auch nichts ändern. Ich denke auch nicht, dass der da jemand anderen ranlässt, also der Leiter der IT macht das natürlich dann auch alles selber.
Ist Slack aus oder ist unser Internet aus? Internet ist aus.
Wir werden nicht mehr gehört.
Nee, eigentlich strömt das hier noch alles.
Also sagt man, nice class.
Was sagt der grüne oder der rote Punkt?
Der grüne Punkt ist grün, aber tatsächlich...
Zumindest Service www, scheinlich.
Naja, wir können jetzt eh nichts dran ändern. Der Ström ist der Ström. Ich guck mal so nebenbei. Ich guck das Thema ja mal zueinander.
Genau, also der Leiter von der IT hat dann auch die DNS-Einträge geändert. So, da muss ich mich um nichts kümmern, aber natürlich Let's Encrypt bzw. bei Engine X noch die Konfiguration machen, die ich natürlich im ersten Moment total vergessen hab, weil wer kommt denn auf die DIPv6-Adressen zu haben? Also war dann erstmal, musste ich das halt auch nochmal neu machen. Jetzt hat mich der Tim mit seinem Blick gerade ein bisschen aus dem Konzept gebracht. Aber was mir dann auch noch super viel weitergeholfen hat, da hatten wir vor Jahren in diesem Podcast auch mal drüber gesprochen. Du hattest das Netz-Stat minus Tulpen, glaube ich, mal erwähnt. Oder je, was das Netz-Stat ist. Also dieses Netz-Stat zusammen hat mir schon mal viel geholfen, um zu gucken, welche Ports gerade wirklich offen sind, von wo kannst du gerade zugreifen auf den Server.
Oh, Internet.
Und das andere war, weil meine bessere Hälfte mir letztens was erzählt hat, dass eine DNS-Eintrag ja natürlich auch irgendwie einen Time-to-Live hat, wie lange der gespeichert wird und abgespeichert wird, bis der neue Inhalt dann wirklich verfügbar gemacht wird für alle. Dann habe ich da halt auch geguckt, weil es gab noch ein Problem und ich dachte so, kann das jetzt daran liegen, dass dieser Time-to-Live noch nicht abgelaufen ist, sodass der neue Inhalt drauf ist. Da muss es doch auch irgendeinen Befehl geben, um diesen Time-to-Live rauszubekommen. Ich bin dann auf Dick gestoßen und es war so, ich merkte so, wow, geil!
Ja, das mache ich zum Beispiel auch mit meinen Studenten. Wenn es dann ums Thema DNS geht, dann gehen wir die ganze Perlenkette von den Root-Name-Servern bis zur Subdomain, jeden Name-Server einzeln mit Dick nach und gucken, was die so sagen und so.
Das war so spannend!
Wenn das meine Studenten so sagen würden.
Das Schlimme ist halt, ich bin da wirklich total begeistert, wie gut das funktioniert hat.
Ja, also Internet basiert ja auf genau diesen Dingen und die funktionieren ja erfahrungsgemäß tatsächlich relativ gut. Aber ja, das ist halt auch immer bei den Studenten dann so. Ich mach so das Terminal auf, dann ist alles schon so, oh, was kommt jetzt? Und dann zeige ich denen halt auch genau so was wie DNS und NetStat und MTR und Traceroute und Whois. Da sind sie ja immer total aus dem Häuschen, wenn man nachgucken kann, wem einer IP gehört. Da stehen dann auch Telefonnummern und IP-Adressen und so. Das finde ich auch total spannend, dass man einfach nachgucken kann, wem eine Domain gehört oder eine IP-Adresse und diese ganzen Sachen.
Genau, das habe ich nämlich, deswegen habe ich da auch eigentlich nachgeschaut, um zu sehen, ob das wirklich schon verändert wurde, ob unter der Domain, die ich da habe, immer noch die AWS liegt oder ob das jetzt wirklich schon mal ein neuer Server ist. Das war einfach großartig, da mal vorwärts zu kommen und so diese Magic, die ich vorher nie selber machen musste, jetzt halt auch mal zu sehen und auch was dir für Möglichkeiten wie dann eben auch im MySQL wirklich geboten werden, um deine Sicherheitsstruktur da irgendwie aufzubauen. Das hat mich halt so nachhaltig geflasht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie voll Bock habe, dann noch mehr zu machen. Und in dem nächsten Projekt, da hab ich halt auch schon zwei Server. Muss ja halt auch noch mit mehr so redirects arbeiten im NGINX. Und ja, also da freu ich mich direkt irgendwie morgen ein bisschen Server-Kraft weiter machen zu können.
Das nächste Level ist dann, also es klingt ja auf jeden Fall schon nach einer sehr soliden down the rabbit hole rein Nerd-Session. Die nächste Stufe ist dann, wenn man ein echtes Metall unter den Fingern hat. Weil dann kann man ja zum Beispiel auch eine MySQL-Datenbank nochmal ganz anders optimieren. Und auch die Wahl des Filesystems, die Blockgrößen, die Read-and-Write-Caches und Ram-Zugriffe und so weiter. Da kann man noch so einiges tunen und so auch auf das Datenzugriffspattern, deine Datenbank hintunen und Performance aus dieser Maschine bekommen, die die ganzen Cloud-Jünger alle gar nicht mehr kennen.
Also wenn ich mich dann...
Wie früher.
Wirklich, weil das ist einfach, begegnet mir immer wieder, dass Leute mittlerweile schon vergessen haben, wie schnell eigentlich Computer sein können, weil die nur an diese Amazon-Instanzen gewöhnt sind, wo irgendwie alles immer so halt nicht so ist, sondern immer so... Immer so ein kleiner Haken dazwischen. Oder durch Virtualisierung, wenn du jetzt halt eine VM hast, die sind mittlerweile schon ziemlich gut, diesen Overhead zu minimieren, aber er ist immer noch da. Und gerade so File System oder Disk IO., wenn irgendwas persistiert werden muss, und irgendwas auf Platte geht oder eben durch den RAM hin und her, dann merkt man das halt schon. Und wir hatten ja bei meinem vorigen Arbeitgeber, bei VUGA, habe ich ja das Business Intelligence, Analytics, Things Bombs, die Infrastruktur halt neu gemacht. Und da sind wir ja von der Cloud auch auf Bare Metal umgezogen. Und haben da, das war so, das war einfach, das war der pure Hardware-Porn und Server-Porn, weil dann die Hauptmaschine war halt so ein Kafka, wo die ganzen Events so reingeströmt sind und der muss halt immer wegschreiben, schreiben, schreiben, schreiben.
Dann hat man so einen richtig fetten Hovel mit viel RAM, mit viel CPUs und dann Spinning Disk für den Hauptstorage, aber dann noch vier SSDs und zwar diese schnellen von Intel damals. Und davon waren zwei Write Cache und zwei Read Cache, zehn Gigabit Ethernet-Karten und dann ging es halt nur darum, die ganze Zeit, wenn wir da jetzt eine 10 Gigabit draufblasen, kriegen wir diese 10 Gigabit auch weggeschrieben und so weiter. Und was für Bursts können wir aushalten und dann eben auch die Datenbank so tunen, dass sie mit dem ZFS klar kam, weil wir ZFS benutzt haben, weil da kannst du halt so Read and Write Caches ziemlich cool einrichten. Das war, da habe ich mich auch so richtig, so wie du das gerade jetzt bei dir beschrieben hast, so auf der Ebene noch mal eins weiter drunter. Und dann hast du halt wirklich auch so das Gefühl, alle Regler mal so in der Hand zu haben. Und dann kommt es auch manchmal so weit, dass man dann wirklich ins BIOS, also quatsch in den SATA-Controller, in die Firmware reinbooten muss, um da mal noch so eine Config umzustellen und plötzlich merkst du, boah, das Fallsystem ist jetzt nochmal irgendwie 50% schneller geworden. Großartig. So was mag ich auch sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gerne. Und das hast du halt natürlich alles in der Cloud weg abstrahiert und natürlich machen die das auch schon so, dass es möglichst optimal ist, aber am Ende ist es halt auch ein Shared Medium.
Ja, vor allen Dingen...
Was man dann im Zweifel leider merkt.
Ja, das zum einen und ich fand halt auch bei Amazon, weil mir teilweise dann, also man, es wird dir halt weg abstrahiert und du verstehst es nicht bis ins Letzte. Das ist halt schade und auch so, was ich auch komisch fand, diese ganzen Kosten. Ich fand halt diese Kostenanalyse da drin hat mir teilweise nicht gesagt, wo passieren denn hier gerade die Kosten? Also ich fand, das ist halt alles so wie so ein bisschen so eine Glaskugel, so, ja gucken wir mal, was bei dem Random diesmal rauskommt und es ist für den Einstieg irgendwie erstmal ganz cool, dass du so ein bisschen rumspielen kannst, wunderbar, aber jetzt freue ich mich auch total darüber, das zu haben und hier hat gerade schon einer darauf hingewiesen, ja, der nächste Schritt ist ein Ansible Playbook zu haben, das weiß ich und das ist das nächste, was ich machen werde.
Ja, das ist auch eine schöne Puzzle-Aufgabe, wenn man das noch nie gemacht hat.
Ja, ich freue mich da gerade voll auf sowas.
Das ist so deklarative Systemadministration, ne?
Also das Ansible ist auf jeden Fall von den ganzen, für mich auch das Sympathischste gewesen, ist aber auch, hat so seine Quirks hier und da, und deswegen meine ich halt so Puzzle-Aufgabe, weil so der einfache Fall geht erstmal ziemlich gut, aber dann fängt es so an so, na ja, jetzt werde ich aber meine Passwörter irgendwie doch anders deployen und verschlüsselt hier und dann, aber wie kriege ich das da rein, ne? Und dann sucht man plötzlich so nach diesen etwas spezielleren Problemen, dann haben wieder tausend Leute unterschiedliche Beispiele und ja, so. Also es ist nicht ganz Quirk-frei, es ist aber auch in den letzten Jahren besser geworden. Und wie gesagt, es war für mich jetzt auch erstmal das Sympathischste, von dem ich verwendet hatte. Ich bin ja gerade den anderen Weg gegangen. Nee, nicht ganz, aber ich habe mich jetzt mal mit Docker beschäftigt.
Das habe ich a, nie verstanden und b, nie genutzt.
Ja, ich habe das jetzt, also ich schreibe gerade, beim gegenwärtigen Projekt einen Chat-Server in Erlangen. Das macht auch gerade mal wieder ausnahmsweise richtig durch Spaß.
Warum machst du es denn in Erlangen?
Ich hörte ja, was ist davon.
Welche andere Sprache fällt dir denn ein, die da besonders gut für geeignet wäre?
Alexia. Na, ich meine, wenn es eh zum Spaß ist, kannst du ja nebenbei auch mal...
Nee, ist ja nicht zum Spaß, ist ja für Arbeit.
Achso, ist ernst.
Ein ernster Chat sozusagen. Aber...
Wir chatten ja hier nicht zum Spaß.
Ja, wie gesagt, Alexia hab ich mir ja schon angeguckt, aber ich find's halt nicht so geil. Also, wie gesagt, für Leute, die noch nie Erlang programmiert haben, ist Alexia sicherlich der einfache Einstieg. Wenn man Erlang schon kann, bietet einem Alexia nicht so viel mehr. Und ich finde auch, es macht so ein paar coole Sachen von Erlang kaputt. Ja, aber Pipes kurdest du dir einmal. Also das ist wirklich so eine Standard-Funktion, die du dir einmal hinschreibst und immer copy- und pastest, dann hast du auch dein Pipe. Es ist zwar nicht so ein schicker Operator, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so viel mehr Overhead. Es ist im Wesentlichen nur ein Fold über eine Liste von Funktionen, die halt ein homogenes Interface haben. Aber das kannst du dir ja genauso auch selber hacken.
Reicht dir dann, kriegst du das auch so hin, dass du immer die Restparameter auch noch mit übergibst?
Das Problem bei Erlang ist halt, dass die Standard-Library sehr konfus ist, weil es halt gewachsen ist. Zum Beispiel Operations of Collections. Manchmal kommt die Collection als erster Parameter und manchmal als letzter Parameter. Oder die Return-Values sind halt je nach Generation von Entwicklern, die Dinge hinzugefügt haben. Manchmal ist es der Wert, manchmal ist es OK und Error-Tupel, manchmal ist es eine Exception, wenn ein Fehler kommt. Das ist eigentlich das Problem, warum man in Erlang so etwas wie Pipe nicht so universell einsetzen kann wie bei Elixir. Aber zum Beispiel, wenn du, sagen wir mal, ein typischer Anwendungsfall für was man so etwas ja auch benutzt ist, du machst einen Spiele-Server, so Bomberman sagen wir mal, und dann hast du deinen Actor, der das Spiel hält und die Kommandos für... Arkadespiel oder Boulder Dash. So was, ne? Einfach Multiplayer-Spiel, wo zwei gegeneinander auf irgendeinem Arkadespiel von mir aus... Bomberman, einfach Bomberman. Kennst du nicht?
Nee, sagt mir jetzt so grad nichts, weil in Arkaden hab ich mir nicht so viel aufgehalten und weiß ja, wie es bei mir ist mit Spielen.
Ganz schlimm. Nimm halt irgendein anderes. Das sind halt zwei Spieler auf der Spielfläche, die irgendwelche Hindernisse vor sich haben, die so mit Bomben wegsprengen und du musst halt dann auch so die Bomben so geschickt legen, dass du im Idealfall deinen Gegenspieler wegsprengst und selber nicht weggesprengt wirst. Anyway, so jetzt hast du so einen Actor, der diese Spielewelt kontrolliert und die verschiedenen Bewegungen der Spieler und Kommandos so entgegennimmt und serialisiert und so weiter und so fort und natürlich den Zustand dieses Spielfeldes verändert. Also welche Steine sind jetzt weggebombt worden, Spielerposition auf dem Spielfeld etc. Und im Prinzip, jetzt kommt so ein Kommando rein, also platzier die Bombe hier und da und sowieso und jetzt hast du diesen Game State, der hat ja irgendein gewisses Format, zum Beispiel bei so einer Arcade-Map wäre es vielleicht ein Koordinatensystem mit den verschiedenen Feldern und was auf den Feldern drauf ist und jetzt platziert er eine Bombe, das heißt dieser Game State muss verändert werden und jetzt hast du sehr spielespezifische Funktionen, wo du ja die API bestimmen kannst und kannst halt sagen, ok die Collection kommt immer als erster Parameter und die Return-Values sind immer in dem Format und für sowas kannst du dann halt ganz easy so ein Pipe Operator oder eine Transform-Funktion, wie ich das dann gerne nenne, halt selber schreiben. Deswegen vermisse ich das da eigentlich nicht, aber bei Elixir ist halt dann der Charme, dass dadurch, dass die Standard Library einmal gewrappt wurde und ein homogenes Interface hat, dass du zum Beispiel so alles, was auf Collections operiert, halt mit diesem Pipe Operator einfach so erschlagen kannst, was in Erlang nicht unbedingt geht. Das ist das Einzige, was ich vielleicht, also wenn ich was an Erlang ändern würde, habe ich bestimmt auch schon mal gesagt, wäre es Standard Library nochmal durchbürsten und auf so das Level von Elixir bringen. Nur Elixir hat hier im Prinzip nur gewrappt. Also das ist immer noch die gleiche Standard Library, nur dass die Interfaces halt mal gewrappt wurden und das könnten sie in Erlang einfach auch genauso mal machen und dann wäre der Schmerz auch weg sozusagen.
Ja, wird ja dann wahrscheinlich auch so eine entsprechende Auswirkung mittelfristig haben. Ich dachte nur so, ich wusste jetzt nicht, dass das sozusagen wirklich ein Auftrag ist, sondern ich dachte, machst du das so als Spaß an der Freude, weil wenn der Hacker langweilig ist, dann schreibt er einen Chatserver?
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, wenn mir langweilig ist, mache ich ganz andere Sachen. Was?
Du bist ja auch gar kein richtiger Hacker.
Ein Hacker zwischen den Welten. Aber auf jeden Fall habe ich da mal wieder eben so Dinge gemacht, die ich lange nicht gemacht habe. Erlang habe ich natürlich schon ein paar Mal gemacht, aber zum einen, weil der halt potenziell auch Open Source werden soll, zumindest meint der Kunde, er möchte den gerne Open Source an den Chatsofa, deswegen lege ich das jetzt auch alles schon so an und habe auch ein Demoklient dazu gemacht, den man dann im Web benutzen kann. Und da habe ich mal wieder so JavaScript und CSS und so verwendet und das habe ich ja wirklich Jahre nicht mehr gemacht, also nicht mehr ernsthaft angeguckt. Je weiter ich mich vom Frontend entfernt habe, desto glücklicher wurde ich ja. Habe ich ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt. Und von deinen Ausführungen höre ich fast ähnliche Tendenzen. Aber da sprechen wir vielleicht später nochmal drüber. Auf jeden Fall habe ich dann so angefangen, wie ich das dann immer so mache. Und dann hier noch so eine Library und dann noch so eine JQuery. Dann ist das mit dem Dom alles ganz einfach. Dann meinte hier die Michaela, die ja auch schon in der Sendung war. Alter, bist du bescheuert? Heutzutage benutzt man noch nicht mehr JQuery. Das musst du alles gar nicht mehr machen. Und ich schicke dir mal ein paar Links. Dann hat sie mir so ein paar Links geschickt. Und für Leute, die vielleicht so wie ich sind und früher Web-Development gemacht haben und auch immer noch so JQuery und Libraries benutzen, um den DOM zu manipulieren, kann ich euch, ich hatte es auch schon getwittert, drei Webseiten mal empfehlen. Die erste heißt schon mal sehr vielversprechend und vollmundig youmightnotneedjquery.com, wo im Prinzip so die üblichsten Sachen, die man halt mit JQuery früher gemacht hat, weil es einfach ein Riesenschmerz war, das mit DOM eigenen Methoden zu machen, gegenübergestellt werden zu wie man das heutzutage macht. Und da sind ein paar dabei, die sind immer noch ziemlich lang, aber es sind auch einige dabei, die sind genauso kurz oder kürzer mit aktuellem ES6 oder ES5 sogar. Und das Schöne ist auf der Seite, da ist alles so für das unterste IE-Level runtergebrochen. Also bei den anderen Browsern funktioniert es eh. Aber wenn du es jetzt auch noch IE-kompatibel machen willst, dann steht immer auf der rechten Seite, was auf jeden Fall auch im IE funktioniert. Fand ich ganz gut. Dann gab es noch eine weitere Seite, wo habe ich jetzt meinen Link hier? Ich mache die Tabs mal am besten gleich auf. Und zwar Choosing Vanilla JavaScript in 2016. Das heißt, der Artikel ist auch schon etwas älter. Aber nichtsdestotrotz fand ich den ganz gut. Da waren nämlich auch einige Beispiele dabei, eben genau das Gleiche. Und da war auch diese neue Fetch-Funktion drin, die du vielleicht auch schon kennst.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt, weil ich mich mit dem neuesten JavaScript heißen Scheiß auch noch nicht erinnern kann.
Das scheint ja auch nicht neu zu sein, wenn es da um 2016 geht. Fetch kannte ich zum Beispiel auch noch nicht. Das ist jetzt quasi so ein ganz moderner asynchronous, also Ajax-Request mit so Promises dran und so Zeug.
Du hast noch alles leere Versprechungen.
Ich hab das selber nie angefangen zu nutzen, weil es ja zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht von allen Browsern unterstützt wurde. Und da war das Problem halt zu groß, dass wenn du im Produktivbetrieb bist, willst du nicht auf so eine unterstützt nicht jeder Browser, du musstest irgendwie transpirieren oder was auch immer der Begriff war.
Transpirieren klingt schon mal gut.
Transpirieren.
Transpirieren, man musste es transpirieren, damit es der Browser wieder verstand. Das war halt so ein bisschen, wo ich mir dachte so, klingt gut, ich bin dann mal kurz weg, ich bin dann mal im Server. Und hab das dann nicht mehr weiterverfolgt.
Für meinen Demoklient ist mir das ja total Pup egal. Ich sage, wenn du einen Browser benutzt, Safari, Chrome, Firefox, alles super, einigermaßen aktuellen Mobilbrowser. Und wenn du jetzt einen Android mit Version 2.4 noch hast, sorry, dann geht's vielleicht nicht, aber das ist für den Demoklient egal, der nur demonstrieren soll, wie man diesen Chat-Server benutzt und wie man mit dem interagiert und so. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ich mach jetzt mal alles, was im Safari geht und der Safari ist ja jetzt mittlerweile der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner fast, wenn man den EE sowieso vor der Tür lässt. Ja, und auf jeden Fall fand ich das ganz cool. Und ich hab jetzt tatsächlich ohne jegliche JavaScript-Library Websockets und DOM-Manipulation und so Zeug gemacht. Das war echt überraschend angenehm im Vergleich zu alten Zeiten. Was mir aber dabei auch aufgefallen ist, wieder ist, was JavaScript einfach für eine kack Sprache ist. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Und das Schöne ist auch, ich meine immerhin sind sie konsequent, auch bei den ganzen neuen Features haben sie genau solche bescheuerten Sachen eingebaut, die die Sprache eh schon immer hatte. Da gibt es so ein paar tolle Talks auf YouTube, wo jemand quasi, ich muss das mal raussuchen in meiner History, quasi so die alten Klassiker, aber auch für die ganzen neuen Funktionen genau so bescheuerten Moves wieder rausgegraben hat, wo irgendwelche Sachen unklar sind. Vielleicht finde ich das gleich noch. Aber was mich so richtig, richtig krass hart stört an JavaScript, ist ja zum Beispiel, kannst du eine Funktion definieren? Die kriegt zwei Parameter, ne? Und jetzt kannst du in diese Funktion keine Parameter, ein Parameter, drei Parameter, eine Million Parameter reinstecken. Es gibt nie einen Fehler. Es ist aber auch nie klar, jetzt, also welcher Parameter wie...
Was, es gibt keinen Fehler, wenn man nicht die richtige Zahl an Parameter steckt?
Naja, die Idee ist ja eigentlich ganz gut, wenn du... Es kommt darauf an, was du für eine Funktion schreibst.
Äh, das, also ich, wirklich, also...
Bitte, was? Ich meine, Moment, die Sprache.
Doch, ja, es ist leider so. Keine ist auch valide, also du kannst doch keine Parameter.
Ich meine, wird die Funktion dann mindestens auch geofen? Ja. Weißt du dann auch, wie viele Parameter sie hat?
Ja. Dann musst du in jeder Scheißsprache gucken.
Also das ist wirklich, ich finde das auch absolut mega behämmert und das erklärt auch sehr viele weitere Idiotismen dieser Sprache. Ich meine, wie gesagt, die Entstehungsgeschichte dieser Sprache ist klar, warum alles so wild ist. Ich finde es aber trotzdem auch komisch, dass sie immer noch so weitermachen.
Man soll zumindest nicht so tun, als ob es sich hier um wirklich eine Sprache handelt, wo sich kluge Leute mal in Ruhe hingesetzt haben und über das Problem von Scripting im Web nachgedacht haben.
Das geile ist auch, es gibt so Videos, wo Leute diese ganzen Quirks und Idiotismen so aufstellen, dann gibt es aber auch die JavaScript-Fanboys, die auch anerkennen, dass es so irgendwie ein bisschen inkonsequent ist und verwirrend und so, aber irgendwie immer noch mit einer Argumentation daherkommen, warum das irgendwie schon irgendwie Sinn machen könnte, also irgendeine Herleitung. Und jeder andere Programmierer, der jetzt nicht JavaScript-Fanboy ist, sitzt so da, das darf doch wohl nicht wahr sein. Also dieser herbeikonstruierte Use-Case, warum dieses Unfeature sinnvoll sein könnte, wirklich, so will man nicht programmieren. Aber ja, wenn man nur schmutzige Gläser kennt oder noch nie ein sauberes Glas gesehen hat, dann sind die schmutzigsten Gläser das beste auf der Welt.
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern, aber diesen Fall mit den beliebig vielen Parametern hatte ich halt in der Tat, als ich damals in meiner Studienzeit irgendwie mal ein Programm, ein Statistikprogramm geschrieben hab. Weil dann kamst du halt nämlich genau mal an so, das war vielleicht auch ein Problem von Java, dass du da irgendwie relativ wenig Konstrukte hattest, wie jetzt, also was Datenstrukturen angeht. Also ich weiß nicht mehr, was das war, aber da war ich halt heilfroh, dass man die Parameter an einer Stelle nicht so festlegen musste, wie viele es sind.
Oh, ich versteh mich nicht falsch. Das ist ja völlig in Ordnung, ein Konzept von variablen Argumenten zu haben. Aber es wäre schon okay, wenn man das auch halt ausschließen kann. Weil es ja auch einfach ein Fehler sein kann. Und Fehler müssen einfach sofort, sofort an der Stelle, wo der Fehler ist, da muss ein Programm enden. Und nicht mit so, auch mal gucken, wie weit wir damit durchkommen und so. Und dann hast du da so einen Stacktrace, der sich wie so dieses neueste Update zur Steuergesetzgebung liest, weil irgendwie so 35 Zeilen untereinander schräg von links oben nach rechts unten durch marschieren, so wie du das bei Java immer so schön hast, wenn da mal der Web-Server sich rollt. Du weißt, was ich meine, ne? Also wurde dann auch überhaupt keine Chance mehr, das rauszufinden, wo eigentlich dieser Scheiß-Fehler jetzt ausgelöst wurde, weil es einfach irgendwo tief im Keller dann geknallt hat, weil oben ja mal eine Murmel die Zappel runtergeworfen hat.
Da muss ich ja sagen, habe ich mich ja sehr bei Python dann irgendwie gefreut, wieder die Möglichkeit von so richtigen Exception-Handling zu haben. Ich glaube, ich habe es wahrscheinlich über benutzt und an Stellen benutzt, wo man es nicht benutzen soll, aber ich war einfach so oh geil, es gibt wieder Exceptions, so richtig geil und hab irgendwie, weil ich auch gerade jemand nachgefragt habe, bei diesem Bibliotheksprojekt, musste ich erstmal Daten ja überhaupt parsen. Und es ist dann so ausgeartet, dass ich halt wirklich so Hunderte von Exceptions einfach für diese Fälle...
Ja, genau, Parsen ist das beste Beispiel, weil du musst halt einfach mit jedem beliebigen Input rechnen, ja. Das ist einfach ein permanentes Fuzzing der eigenen Schnittstellen und du kannst einfach nicht ahnen, was auf dich zugerollt kommt. Es kommt potentiell einfach alles. Und eine Sprache muss einfach in der Lage sein, erstmal die Fälle, die du kennst, von allen anderen klar zu trennen. Das ist einfach schon mal eine Grundvoraussetzung. Da scheitern 90 Prozent aller Programmiersprachen da draußen schon.
Und das Ding ist natürlich, in Erlang ist es ja besonders, also das krasse Gegenteil, weil du hast ja dieses Pattern Matching. Das heißt, du sagst jetzt hier, die Funktion addieren gibt es in 25 verschiedenen Varianten. Je nachdem, wie die Argumente sind, kannst du halt dann das Pattern Matchen oder auch nach Typen oder was auch immer.
Oder wie deine Daten sind, die hier reinkommen.
Das ist ja das, was in, also ich kenne das aus Java noch, da hieß es, glaube ich, überladen von Funktionen.
Ja, das ist eine ganz andere Baustelle.
Das überladen von Funktionen, das sind alles schon so fixes.
Aber das geht in diese Richtung, dass du eben unterscheiden kannst, je nachdem was drin ist, ob du deine Berechnung halt auch anpasst an das?
Ja, vielleicht musst du es mal gesehen haben, dann wird der Unterschied vielleicht noch klarer als jetzt von so einer Erzählung, aber auf jeden Fall ist es so, dass das sofort ein Fehler ist, wenn du sozusagen keine Funktionen hast, die auf die Inputs matchen. Also wenn du halt irgendwie drei Argumente statt zwei erforderlichen reinsteckst oder eins zu wenig oder was auch immer. Und es gibt die Option, du kannst natürlich immer sagen, ja akzeptier doch einfach ein Hash als Argument und dann kannst du in den Hash reintun, was immer du willst oder ein Array von, die Option hat ja jede Sprache im Wesentlichen, dass du, wenn du nur ein Argument hast, dann so eine Collection hast. Aber wie gesagt, wie Tim schon sagte, es muss eine Unterscheidung davon geben und nicht einfach, egal auf welcher Ebene, in welcher Dimension du bist. Millionen Argumente, kein Argument, ein Argument, fünf Argumente, alles geht, kommen sie ran.
Das ist die Stärke dieser Erlangwelt, dass sie halt von vornherein die Sprache genau für Stabilität und Rigidität entwickelt haben. Und dieses Konzept, das nennt man ja als Fail Early. Also wenn irgendwas auch nur ansatzweise droht falsch zu laufen, sofort die Handbremse ziehen und irgendwie Motor aus.
Und aber auch gleichzeitig noch ein Konzept, das Ding wieder auch am Laufen zu halten. Was ich ja auch schon mal meinte, der große Unterschied von Erlang zu so ziemlich jeder anderen Runtime ist, dass der Default-Zustand ist, das System läuft und nicht, ah, wir sind jetzt am Ende des Quelltextes angekommen, das heißt, ich beende mich jetzt. Nein, nein, nein, stopp, stopp, pass auf, hier ist noch so eine Socket offen, poll die doch einfach noch mal ein bisschen weiter und wenn da was kommt, dann starten wir wieder von vorne. Das ist halt so, bei jeder anderen Programmiersprache musst du eigentlich darum kämpfen, dass das Programm weiterläuft, weil das natürliche Bestreben eines Programms ist, sich zu beenden, wenn es fertig ist. Und du musst immer sagen, ne, ne, ne, stopp, halt, warte, hier ist noch, selecte nochmal auf die Socket-Poll nochmal, guck doch nochmal. Bei Erlang ist halt einfach der Default-Zustand, du startest das System und das System bleibt an. Und wenn ein Fehler kommt, dann gibt es einen dedizierten Weg, wo du sagen kannst, starte, zum Beispiel, wenn dieser Teil der Applikation fehlschlägt, starte alle Komponenten neu. Oder wenn dieser Teil der Applikation fehlt, der ist nicht kritisch, starte einfach nur die Komponente neu und so. Und du hast halt einfach einen Weg zu definieren, wie du im Fehlerfall auch so dein System in einem same Zustand hältst und so weiter. Und das gibt es halt sonst nicht.
Ja, also...
Ja, gut, das ist jetzt aus Java.
Schau mal, ich nehme dir gerade so schöne Java-Stick-Trays an.
Ja, und am Ende findest du so eine Singleton-Klasse, die irgendwie eine Property von einem Integer überlädt. Alles schon gesehen. Alles schon gesehen.
So, irgendwie wollten wir heute doch früher Schluss machen. Hat auch nicht geklappt.
nicht so richtig.
Ja, weiß nicht, vielleicht noch kurz...
Guck mal, egal...
.die Disten noch leer machen.
So ein Flush noch hier hinten raus.
Kurzer Tipp hier vielleicht mal an die Podcasts. Ich weiß nicht, kann ich Tipp sagen? Ich hab das Ding gerade entdeckt irgendwie. Du hast mir davon erzählt.
Ach so, ja doch.
Das kann man vielleicht mal erwähnen. Also ich weiß noch nicht, ob das Ding taucht, aber scheint sehr interessant zu sein. Zoom, hier die Bude, die ja schon so das eine oder andere interessante Produkt gemacht hat. Die haben jetzt...
Ich glaube Anfang des Jahres zur NAMM-Show haben sie das announced. Da hab ich das gesehen und dachte halt sofort, das ist irgendwie das Proberaum-Recording-Device, aber dann bin ich gerade in die Meta-Ebene reingelaufen und hab Tims Mobil-Recording-Koffer gesehen und dachte mir, das ist eigentlich auch die perfekte Podcast-Station.
Das kann gut sein, und zwar handelt es sich hier um so ein Gerät, das sieht erstmal aus, wie ein Mixer ist eigentlich auch einer. Hat so typische 19 Zoll Kofferbreite und hat acht Mikrofoneingänge, was ja schonmal ganz ordentlich ist, oder Line-In nehme ich an, bzw. ganz richtig ist es, acht Mikroeingänge mit Line-In und dann noch mal zwei Stereo Analog- oder Stereo USB-Eingänge. Das heißt, man kann über das USB-Interface vier Kanäle empfangen und all diese ganzen empfangenen Kanäle plus den Master, also 14 Kanäle gehen dann über USB auch wieder raus. Und das Ding hat SD-Karten und kann alles auch Multitrack aufnehmen. Wir haben uns gerade das Blog-Schaltbild angeschaut, das habe ich jetzt nicht in der Hand gehabt. Ich mache bei diesen Zoom- und Audio-Geräten immer als erstes das Handbuch runter und gucke auf die letzte Seite, weil da sind diese Blog-Schaltbilder und da steht die Wahrheit. Da weiß man dann wirklich, was hier wirklich mit verbunden ist und was für merkwürdige Quirks da sind. Da sind auch so ein paar urige Design-Decisions drin, aber im Wesentlichen scheint mir das erstmal ganz brauchbar zu sein. Sieht also so aus, als ob es jetzt hier ein Gerät gibt, was nicht nur sehr viele Mikrofone anschließen kann, nämlich bis zu acht. Nein, es hat sogar, Halleluja, wie lange muss ich darauf warten, es hat fünf Kopfhörerausgänge eingebaut. Das heißt, man muss nicht nochmal irgendeinen dusseligen Kopfhörerverstärker da anschließen. Hauptsache, die taugen, aber ich vermute mal, das kriegen sie hin. Und kann für jeden einzelnen Kopfhörer auch einen eigenen Mix machen und natürlich auch Volumen letzten Endes einstellen. Du hast auch noch so Equalizer-Funktionen und so weiter, ob man die braucht, weiß ich nicht.
Kompressor vielleicht noch am besten?
Genau, Kompressor ist drauf und ist auch einstellbar mit so einem Drehregler. Also man hat den Gain und einen Kompressor pro Kanal. Kann nur noch sagen, ob das Ding aufgezeichnet werden soll, wobei das Block-Schaltbild sich da ein bisschen widerspricht. Das muss man mal wirklich testen. Man hat dann halt einen Master-Mix und einen Main-Out. Und macht so den Eindruck, als könnte das eine ganz interessante Live-Podcast-Maschine sein. Weil da stellt man nämlich auf den Tisch, hat bis zu acht Kanäle, die man anschließen kann, kann direkt auf SD-Karte aufnehmen und ist so standalone einfach schon mal startklar. Ich würde sagen, taugt jetzt mal für bis zu fünf Leute. Mehr macht selten Sinn. Gibt so Situationen, Sendezentrum, Kongressa, da sitzen noch mal acht, aber das ist jetzt ein bisschen extrem. Ich würde sagen, mit fünf Kopfhörer-Ports kommt man schon hin. Ja, und dann kann man damit aufnehmen. Und wenn ich es richtig sehe, wie gesagt, noch nicht getestet, aber wenn ich das richtig sehe, kann man das Ding dann auch, wie das bei Zoom eigentlich üblich ist, das Ding auch als USB-Multi-Track-Device ohne Treiberinstallation verwenden. Sprich, ich gehe davon aus, dass man das an den Rechner anschließt und dann hat man das USB-Device mit 14 Eingängen mit 4 Ausgängen. Und wenn man dem Block-Schaltbild glauben darf, kann man halt über die USB-Ausgänge was rüber schicken. Das geht direkt in den Mix und man kriegt es auch über USB wieder zurück. Also nicht so separat, weil früher bei den anderen Geräten war das immer alles so separat. Und es sieht auch so aus, als ob man das dann alles mit aufnehmen kann. Das heißt, auch was man per USB da hinschickt in den Mix, kann man auch als einzelne Tracks, links und rechts Kanal, getrennt aufnehmen auf der SD-Karte und kriegt es auch wieder zurück per USB. Ja, und damit ist es sowohl für meinen bevorzugten Einsatz, nämlich mit Reaper da direkt rangehen und alles schön auf dem Bildschirm haben und was auf so einem Rechner ist, ist safe so. Aber eben auch noch die SD-Karte mit laufen lassen, immer um ein Backup zu haben. Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool, weil das ist immer so auf dünnem Eis.
Ich glaube, das hat ja auch das Feature, was der H6 hat, wo man ja sogar zwei Recordings gleichzeitig machen kann. Nämlich eins nochmal mit minus 10 dB oder sowas. Das kann der H6 auf jeden Fall. Das ist so für Proberaumaufnahmen ganz geil, weil man halt den initialen Pegel einstellt und dann kommt doch so ein Song, wo man doch ein bisschen lauter rockt und dann klippt irgendwie alles. Und dann gibt es aber noch so ein Backup-Recording. Ich glaube, das ist dann nur vom Mastermix. Was 10 dB niedriger ist. Und ich glaube, der hat das Feature dann auch nochmal. Wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Und ich hab das irgendwie auch so zum Jahres, also nach Januar irgendwann gesehen und hab dann auch auf YouTube mir so Leute angeguckt, die das schon mal so benutzt haben. Das war alles so im Musikkontext, aber zumindest die Benutzung und wie sie das so benutzt, also ja, wie das User Interface war, sah alles ziemlich cool aus. Auf der Zoom-Seite selbst haben die jetzt auch so eine Liste von Videos verlinkt. Die sind wahrscheinlich alle ein bisschen Marketing-kompatibler so und ein bisschen hochwertiger produziert, aber es gibt auch wie gesagt schon ein paar Videos von Leuten, die unabhängig das benutzt haben und auch alle sehr begeistert schienen davon. Also ich habe auch schon darüber nachgedacht, weil eben das jetzt so für Live-Sachen eben weil auch ein Mixer quasi mit drin ist. Also man kann das auch für den Main-Out auf die Monitorboxen als Mixer dann gleich verwenden. Das wäre halt so für Proberaum-Situationen super und wahrscheinlich auch für die eine oder andere Live-Event-Besparung ganz cool. Also halbes Digital-Mischpult-Recorder.
Monitor-Out.
Ist auf jeden Fall mal ein interessantes Gerät und ich würde es auch gerne mal testen. Mal sehen.
Ja, man hat auch gleich so die Pegel drauf. Das ist auch irgendwie ganz hilfreich.
Ja und das Schöne ist halt, natürlich hat so ein Gerät jetzt keine Motorfader, weil das dann halt doch ein bisschen das Gerät klobiger macht in der Regel. Aber wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe in den Videos, dann wenn man so Presets aufruft, von Recordings oder alte Recordings wieder aufruft, dann zeigen die LEDs neben den Fadern auch an, wo die Fader eingestellt waren, sodass man zumindest so ein bisschen Recall von den, also man sieht einfach, wie die Fader eingestellt werden. Genau und kann da potenziell auch wieder hinfahren.
Ja, also wenn das stimmt, das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Option. Und man hat halt auch direkt so ein Recording-Interface, das heißt, man kann das auch mit dem Recording nicht vergessen. Also ich werde da mal drüber nachdenken. Das sieht ganz, ganz, ganz nice aus. Auch wenn es natürlich nicht wie mein Fokus-Ride Clarett mir die Software-Only-Variante bereitstellt, die ich ja eigentlich machen wollte. Aber jetzt, wenn ich mein Gerät nicht wiederkriege... Bitte melde dich! Bitte melde dich, wer immer du warst. Wem auch immer ich vertraut habe. Du bist so unglaublich... Ich hab grad vergessen, wer du bist. Ist ja auch ein Kompliment, ne? Ich hab vergessen, wer du bist. Aber du warst mein Gerät.
Der Spaß hat jetzt lange genug gedauert. Tim hatte mich ganz verzweifelt angeschrieben und meinte so, hast du mein Focusrite-Gerät? Ich hab ihn alle angeschrieben.
Ich dachte mir, irgendeiner von euch muss es doch gewesen sein, verdammte AX.
Aber ich danke jetzt mal anonym einer Person. Auch wenn sie... Die dir neulich ein Focusrite-Gebrauch verkauft hat. Aber das nicht. Ich war in einer ähnlichen Situation wie du. Vor Jahren gab es auf Amazon gerade die gebundene Ausgabe Hardcover von der Principia Discordia. Und wir wissen ja alle, jede Ausgabe von der Principia Discordia, die man auf Amazon kaufen kann, ist natürlich so ein Reprint von irgendwem. Aber die war tatsächlich so schönes Hardcover.
Welche, die gelbe?
Dunkel mit goldenen Symbolen.
War das die... Ja, also das ist ja nochmal so eine ganze Wissenschaft für sich, ne? Principia Discordia, ist das die mit den mehreren Intros hintereinander?
Ich glaube ja.
Das ist die gute.
Also das war auch wirklich, ich hab lange recherchiert, weil es gab auch viel Crap.
Es gibt viel Crap, die sind nicht so vollständig. Man muss halt mindestens die Introduktion von Carrie Thornton haben.
So, und dann irgendwann wollte ich die mal wieder so rauskramen und stellte fest so, fuck, die ist nicht da. Alles durchsucht und ich war so richtig in so einem Rage-Modus, so okay, ich geh jetzt an jedes Regal, ich guck in jedem Winkel unter jeden Stapel, die muss hier sein. Und dann irgendwann ist mir das auch so ähnlich wie bei Tim irgendwie gekommen, ich hab die glaube ich irgendwie im Verliehen. Selber... Ich hab mich irgendwie verflucht, was für ein Idiot, wieso verleist du dieses wertvolle Stück Information an irgendwen? Und dann hab ich auch überlegt, okay, wer könnte sich denn überhaupt für so was interessieren? Es gibt ja nicht viele Leute, die von der Prinzipia discordia wissen oder sie schätzen oder genug schätzen, um sich dieses Buch auszuleihen. Und dann hab ich die wenigen Leute, die mir eingefallen sind, angeschrieben und alle so, nee, nee, nee, das wüsste ich, wenn ich so was hätte. Also nee, also ich bin mir ganz sicher, ne? Und jetzt nach, weiß nicht, über einem Jahr hab ich so eine Nachricht bekommen, so übrigens, Pust, ich hab gerade deine Prinzipia discordia gefunden. Und ich hab sie seit letztem Wochenende wieder in meinem Besitz und sie ist auch unbeschadet und in sehr gutem Zustand und ich bin wieder ganz froh. Und deswegen hab ich auch sehr mit dir mitgelitten, weil genau zu diesem Zeitpunkt, als ich diesen Verlust mit dieser Prinzipia discordia feststellte, schrieb mir Tim mit seinem Audio-Interface und genau das gleiche. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich es geliehen hab. Und dafür gibt es ja eigentlich auch Apps, auch Bücher verleihen ist ja eigentlich so das ätzendste überhaupt, weil man kriegt ihn nie wieder. Also ist mein Erfangen in den seltensten Fällen.
Deswegen verleihe ich Bücher nur an sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gute Freunde und wenn mir die Bücher zu lange nicht zurückgegeben werden, dann frage ich dann schon ein bisschen nach, wie sieht es denn aus? Hast du das Buch schon gelesen? Ich bräuchte es dann doch.
Zum Beispiel, und das ist jetzt wirklich die letzte Anekdote, bevor ich hier fertig bin, dann meine Rede beiträgen. Es gibt ein Typografie-Buch. Äh, äh, von Hans-Peter Wilberg. Typolemic heißt das. Das ist gelb und es wird nicht mehr gedruckt. Und ich hatte dieses Buch. Und mir fallen drei Leute ein, denen ich das geliehen haben könnte. Alle drei sagen, ich hab das Buch nicht. Noch nie gehabt, noch nie gesehen. Ich bin mir so sicher, einer von den drei naht es aber. Ich hatte solche Sehnsuche nach diesem Buch, dass ich mir das dann auf so einem Antiquariat-Dingsbums gekauft hab für einen nicht zu teuren Preis. Und es hatte sogar eine Signatur von Hans-Peter Wilberg drin. Also eine Widmung an den ursprünglich beschenkten oder wie auch immer. Das heißt, ich hab jetzt einen Upgrade sogar von diesem Buch bekommen durch Mehrfachkauf. Ja, hier guck mal, da wollen wir heute 178 Euro für das Buch haben. Das ist echt auch bescheuert.
Gebundene Ausgabe 25,99 Euro.
Ja, aber es sind Gebrauchte halt, ne? Ja, die sind halt manchmal dann auch in einem scheiß Zustand. Also ich hab auch überall geguckt und ich wollte halt eins, was mindestens in so einem guten Zustand ist wie meins. Hab ich jetzt auch bekommen.
Gebraucht wie neu.
Ja, ich hab meins für 39 Euro, glaub ich, bekommen. Aber es ist, also du siehst, es gibt nicht super viele davon. Man kann das auch noch kaufen, wenn ihr das, wenn ihr euch für Typografie interessiert und so. Ich kann das sehr empfehlen. Das ist so, es ist nicht so ein Fachbuch, wo es so da, so das ist richtig, das ist falsch, sondern das ist ein Fleece-Text. Ja, also eine Geschichte. Und dabei behandelt er halt so bestimmte typografische Aspekte. Und ich fand das ein sehr, sehr schönes Buch. Und ich wurde daran erinnert, weil mein derzeitiger Arbeitgeber ein neues Logo hat, mit dem ich nicht einverstanden bin. Und das musst du dann gleich... Das ist jetzt so, aber deswegen hatte ich mich an dieses Buch erinnert, weil Typolemik, also es geht auch so ein bisschen um Kritik und so an Design und Gestaltung. Weil es gibt ja den Spruch, über Geschmack lässt sich nicht streiten, aber ich bin definitiv der Meinung, dass es gutes und schlechtes Design gibt. Und das ist so auch absolute Wahrheit.
Das war jetzt deine Aussage oder du zitierst da jemanden?
Das ist meine Aussage. Ich kenne zumindest einige Designer, Freunde aus alten Zeiten, die das auch ähnlich sehen. Ja, und dieses Buch ist so eine Unterfütterung dieser These, weil ja, naja, wie gesagt.
Mir geht es gerade andersrum, dass ich seit wahrscheinlich auch seit fast zehn Jahren, ja, wahrscheinlich wirklich seit zehn Jahren, habe ich eine Dauergeleihgabe eines Freundes, die gesammelten Werke von Klaus Kinski eingesprochen, also so verschiedene Werke, die Klaus Kinski da liest. Und ich habe immer noch seine CD-Sammlung. Ja, ja, bei dir steht sie doch ganz gut.
Ich habe keinen CD-Play mittlerweile mehr.
Ich auch nicht mehr. Ja, dann natürlich habe ich sie gerückt. Aber ich habe immer noch diese wunderschöne Klaus Kinski-Sammlung jetzt bei mir in meinem Regal stehen. Und ich erinnere ihn jedes Mal. Soll ich sie dir mitbringen? Nö, nö. Gut. Bleibt sie halt bei mir. Geht auch andersrum. Man versucht verzweifelt, die Sachen wieder riss zu werden.
Das ist eigentlich auch eine gute Strategie umso.
Klaus Kinski höre ich sofort schreie und...
Also er hat... Also seine...... Ja, und seine Stimme ist einfach grandios in den Werken. Ich guck grad mal. Also wirklich Schiller, Goethe.
Also das ist ein Genie und Wahnsinn, dass es auch wirklich selten in einer Person so näher miteinander vereint oder nah beieinander wie bei Herrn Kinski. Aber ich hab dann auch mit dem Thema relativ bald abgeschlossen, nachdem ich dann diese eine Szene, ich weiß nicht, ob das war bei Fitzcarraldo oder so, wo sie das Boot über den Berg hiefen wollten oder so, und einer der Kameramänner von so einer Schlange gebissen wurde, die relativ giftig war und der sich dann mit der Kettensäge irgendwie das Bein abhacken musste, um zu überleben und Klaus Kinski nicht er tragen konnte, dass jetzt die ganze Aufmerksamkeit nicht bei ihm lag und er sich lauthals darüber beschwerte, dass er jetzt keinen Kaffee hätte oder irgendeine Belanglosigkeit und so. Das war einfach so eine Situation, wo ich dachte, okay, Alter, wirklich, geh kacken.
Nee, der ging gar nicht. Der war einfach nur erstaunlich. Wie soll ich sagen? Der war einfach nur erstaunlich in seinem Wahn. Und ich meine, gefühlt gab es niemanden, zu dem der nett war. Ich meine, noch nicht mal seine Kinder kamen mit ihm klar.
Wahrscheinlich kam er selber mit sich auch nicht klar.
Der kam auch mit sich selber nicht klar.
Aber wie gesagt, die Werke der Weltliteratur von ihm sind auf jeden Fall eine Empfehlung.
Ja, verstehe.
Also ich stimme zu.
Wollen wir den Tim mal die Nachtruhe gönnen?
Uns allen?
Ja, uns allen. Du wolltest ja eigentlich nicht so lang machen.
Aber du quatschst halt auch ein bisschen.
Na, wenn man die Letty mal lässt, dann ist da auch kein Ende in Sicht.
Ich hab mich nur angepasst.
So soll es sein.
Bist du warm geworden mit der Freak Show.
Bleibst du noch ein bisschen.
Mir wurde ja auch am Wochenende wieder gesagt, dass es toll ist, dass ich dabei bin.
Ja, ist ja auch so.
Das unterschreiben wir alle.
Ja, aber es ist nach wie vor komisch, wenn Leute zu dir ankommen oder sagen, die Stimme kenn ich aber. Oder hier die Situation auf dem, hier was was, Kongress mit dem Mini-Hörer treffen. Das war so ein bisschen so, da ging es nicht weiter nach hinten, da war dann der Abgrund, da konnte man sich nicht verstecken. Da ist noch ein bisschen ungewohnt.
Ja, wir hatten neulich mal nachgeguckt, wie viele Einsätze du jetzt eigentlich schon hattest, ich bin volljährig, ich bin jetzt 19 sogar schon. Du hast mitgezählt.
Ich konnte mir das bei dem 18 merken.
Ja, okay, du kannst es dir noch merken, das ist doch gut. Ich kann es mir nicht mehr merken. Hast du dir gemerkt, wie oft du dabei warst?
Der Huckel war gar nicht da.
Soll ich dir mal sagen, Huckel?
Ja, bitte sehr gerne.
Das ist heute dein 132. Einsatz. Nix mehr mit Stimme der Jugend und so. Altes Eisen. Also ich meine, das ist schon ein bisschen was.
Haben wir denn eigentlich einen Sendungstitel?
Bitte melde dich, hat dich jemand vorgeschlagen.
Guck mal gerade noch, ob es für 213 noch einen HTTP-Status-Code gibt, aber ich glaube, 213 ist nicht belegt.
Ich glaube, die 404. Folge, da machen wir richtig einen Fass auf. Das ist die beste. All right.
208 wäre ja sehr geil gewesen. Already reported.
Jetzt sind wir wieder raus aus den Pedercodes.
Schnell, bei 300 geht es weiter.
Müssen wir noch ein bisschen durchhalten. Gut, Leute, ich würde sagen, damit machen wir jetzt hier langsam mal Schluss. Und gucken wir mal, wie wir uns dann so in zwei Wochen wieder schlagen. Wenn es wieder weitergeht mit der Freak Show. Wir bedanken uns fürs Zuhören und sagen Tschüss und bis bald.